You're saying how,
how promotions work?
Yeah.
Here we go.
Four,
three,
two,
one.
So Tom pop and I are sitting here.
USA.
Do you,
did you see the fight on Saturday night?
And he said,
the guy that got knocked down,
mental health,
mental health guy,
the guy got up for everyone with mental
health.
But you said no,
I didn't see the fight.
Like I only saw.
I only saw that.
How narratives work.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like in this day and age especially,
there's way too much information out
there,
right?
Like there's no way you could see every
television show or watch every sporting
event or,
or no,
every scandal.
So when something happens,
like the blurb,
the,
the little summary that I have absorbed,
my,
my one buddy watched it on instagram,
he posted a thing and it was very
heartfelt that he got up for all the
people with mental health.
And uh,
I read that and I feel like I
experienced the whole thing.
But,
you know,
it's funny,
I don't know if he won or lost.
I know he got to draw,
draw,
draw.
Okay.
And uh,
I don't have a firm opinion on whether
or not the draw was justified because I
only watched it once.
I thought I thought that Tyson fewer one
most of the rounds except the two that
he got knocked down in tysons.
The anti mental health guy.
No,
he's the white guy who,
he's the white guy that got knocked down
and Deontay wilder.
He's.
Is he strange in that?
He has like the most freaky punching
power I think I've ever seen ever.
That's what I heard too.
Big Guy.
I mean for a heavyweight.
He's 212 pounds.
He looks pretty big though.
He's Jack.
He shredded.
He has no fat on them whatsoever.
Back is where all the power is.
And that's where I was.
His muscle is like,
you see his back.
It's just fucking,
just a bundle of snakes.
But I saw the clip.
He knocked him out and then backed up
and dance.
Iceland got up.
Yeah.
That guy.
Fuck that guy.
Wilder punches so hard.
And that was in the twelfth and final
round.
That was a fight where he was mostly
losing.
He was mostly getting boxed up.
It was mostly getting out boxed,
but then he would land and he landed
real hard and like,
what was it,
like the eighth or the ninth,
something like that,
something like that.
He dropped him,
but that wasn't a big knockdown.
He knocked him down,
but he got up pretty quick and he was.
He was okay,
but in the twelfth he fucking blasted
him.
He hit him with a right hand and then as
he was falling,
he hit him with a left hook on the chin
as he was going down,
like any laid flat on his back with his
arms down.
He looked unconscious.
Yeah,
he really did.
And then he rose like Lazarus and he
looked pretty sharp when he got on his
feet,
one of the rest of the round,
he wanted to rest around the stung him.
He stunned.
Deontay wilder.
It was crazy because of the mental
health kids.
Yes.
He was doing it for the mental health
people.
You think that's really what he was
thinking when you're getting up off the
canvas?
I'm doing it for the kid.
I would never doubt him.
Yeah,
he.
He really does.
He's,
he's in a very unusual guy and he
donated his entire purse to charity.
It like $8 dollars.
Really?
Yeah.
He donated all of it to charity.
Holy Cow.
That's great.
These are fucking really unusual guy.
He was.
He's been in here.
He was in the podcast when he was
gearing up for the fight,
so I should call them the super nice
mental health guy.
He's a very nice guy.
Very nice guy.
Big giant six,
nine,
sixth.
So he was sitting here.
You feel like he's shoes?
A giant,
super sweetheart.
Friendly Guy.
Geez.
You're really well spoken.
He's got that heavy travelers accent.
He's a traveler.
Had He made money before?
Oh yeah.
He's a world champion,
so he's like,
he was a world champion bank and almost
killed himself in a Ferrari,
almost committed suicide and he was
headed towards a bridge.
He was going gonna fucking either
slamming into the bridge or drive off
the bridge.
That was his.
Yeah,
he was going 60 miles an hour,
like headed towards the bridge and you
change his mind.
That's what he looked like before he
started his comeback.
Yeah,
he was 300 pounds,
300 plus,
right.
How much they say it was safe for 85,
but yeah,
something crazy because he's saying 300
kilograms.
So that's like,
what is it?
Close to 400 pounds.
Oh my God.
He's.
So he was champion and he fell off and
became that Chubby.
Well,
what happened was he beat Vladimir
Klitschko who was a long time
heavyweight champion.
I mean flooded Makoto was there,
remember champ forever.
And he out boxed him like soundly
outboxed him and beat him and then was
like now what?
And went into a depression and start
drinking hard,
partying,
hard.
A lot of cocaine and just fucked his
life up just as he achieved what he
wanted to achieve.
I mean he's calling it mental health,
you know,
because of depression and all those
things.
But part of me wants to say that a lot
of that is.
I mean,
I don't know,
obviously I've never been inside of his
head,
but when you're doing that much coke and
drinking that much,
that is got to be a major factor in why
you feel like shit.
And then the let down of this incredible
achievement becoming the heavyweight
champion of the world,
beating this guy who hadn't been beat in
a long time,
many,
many years,
and then you know,
just partying too hard and then getting
into a horrible funk and deciding to
come back.
So is that part of it where you know,
you know,
that you have that.
There are those personalities and
there's genetics involved and he gets
you into the drugs,
but then the drugs start going to work
on your brain and then it becomes
something different.
It becomes no longer your own
consciousness that's working.
It's this sponge that just absorbs all
of these toxins and who knows what's
misfiring,
what's happening at that point.
We say that as we drink wine.
Cheers.
Happy holidays.
Thank you for heroin in the holidays.
Whatever little fucking meth.
I was going to bring you some wine
today.
This was nice you to open this.
This is good stuff.
Whatever this is.
I don't know Jack Shit about one.
I learned a great method for
Thanksgiving wine.
What's the.
I went to this place in la.
It's called a 2020 wine.
It's like this.
It looks like right here.
This is the last dark.
It's on the,
on the four.
Oh five.
And you just walk in and just wine.
This huge room racks and stuff.
It's so elegant.
It's just like this great place to be.
It's cool.
It's like temperature wise,
it's like it's great and it's
intimidating because they have,
you know,
I don't know that much about wine I want
to,
but.
And I realized this was my strategy and
it worked out perfectly.
I went to the guy who works there and I
said,
look,
I have 12 people coming over for
thanksgiving.
Show me a $20 bottle of wine or less
that I can buy a bunch of for my friends
that's going to blow everyone away.
And he lit up like a Christmas tree.
It's like,
this is what he wants to do.
yeah,
there's 200 bottles,
dollar bottles of wine.
We know what that is.
I'm going to come with me and there it
is.
And he took me into the back and he
found these.
He's like,
this one's from Spain,
$18.
No one knows it exists.
The best wine I've had all year,
another one and this Italian Barolo that
nobody knows about it,
and look at this,
it's only $12 a bottle because nobody
knows we have an extra cases.
It became like his.
Of course,
that's what a wine guy wants to do.
Turn you on.
Is the wine thing that a name is just as
important as how good it is?
Sure,
yeah.
Like when people,
you know,
an opus one or a famous or like,
we all know that because that's like the
Mercedes of wines.
Cigars are like that as well.
I know more about to go.
I don't know much about cigars,
but I know more about cigars that I know
about wine and like everybody wants a
Cuban cute Cohiba oh,
wants something that's
hard to get.
Yeah.
But this was.
I was like,
Oh,
this is how you should do it.
Find a good wine shop and go to the guy
who's waiting to be asked that question
and he so excited to show you what he
learned and he works in a wine shop.
So he's not spending $500 for a bottle
either.
Me and my shit.
My Buddy Mark Telegraph and I were in
Florida.
We're eating this very nice time
restaurant with a bunch of people from
the UFC.
We just said,
let's get a nice bottle of wine.
You're have a nice bottle of wine.
I'm like,
I've had good bottles of wine,
but this place had like bought bottles
wine from the seventies.
Right.
So I said,
all right,
let's go fucking crazy.
I bought a bottle of wine from 1974.
Oh my God,
this is better.
This is better.
This one's better.
It was like,
it was weird.
I guess if you're a real connoisseur,
like part of it is like Roberto Duran
was the champ when this will bottled
stuff and stuff about.
It was in the third grade,
something Mrs Mcmillan.
It was like,
it felt like it had less alcohol.
And I think that's,
uh,
one of the things that maybe happens,
the flavor sorts starts to morph and
change.
It just felt less
potent,
almost more watered down.
It wasn't that good.
I enjoyed it,
but I didn't love it.
Right.
And that,
you know,
and you probably paid a lot for.
It was like a thousand dollars.
I'm not joking.
Yeah,
I think it was a thousand dollar bottle
of wine.
I'm telling you,
this Thanksgiving we had it.
It was $18 bottles of wine.
It's probably way bigger.
Heads off.
Yeah,
probably way better.
So great.
They're there,
you know,
I try and learn about them and there are
certain wines they say like there's
certain Brunellos that like those should
age and those you can go like 20 years
and you know,
they'll get even better at 30 and then
there's other wines at that same amount
of time.
They'll go sour and they'll get funky.
So it's so hard to tell.
Yeah.
APP that I have,
I've never fucking opened at.
Once I had downloaded it.
It's like Vino Vino,
we almost went down with that write on
the board.
Oh,
it's got a power ballad.
Nice.
Because that was headed towards the
board team.
Same.
He's not even drinking.
I don't fuck with laptops in front of me
anymore.
I've learned my lesson.
I was doing a show on Saturday.
My friend had a laptop,
she had a glass of water and a salad on
the keyboard.
I'm like,
what are you having a gun in your baby's
head?
Rest your head on the gun separated now,
but this was,
this was such a great way to do it.
I mean there's so you can focus in on
one kind of wine and really kind of
learn it and that's a lot like that
would be a lot of studying to learn all
of wine and like go into a fancy
restaurant and be like,
I'm just going to pick from you.
Can,
you know?
It's one of those things where you have
to.
You really have to talk to someone who's
putting the time.
Yes,
totally.
That's,
yeah,
my keys.
Here's something that I know a lot about
pool cues,
right?
I know a lot about pool,
so if you come to me and you say,
Hey,
I'm thinking about buying this pool cue,
what do you think of?
Okay,
well here's what you need to know.
Like that's a.
that's a very expensive pool cue and
it's expensive because it's a
collector's item because the guy who
makes it as dead.
However,
in terms of like how it plays,
it does not play any better than a pool
cue that crossed one small fraction of
what that costs and then I could turn
you onto a bunch of custom pool cue
makers that make a really good cue for a
fraction of what you would pay for that
cue and I'm telling you like you would
play with this queue and be happy with
it for the rest of your life,
but it will cost you $500 as opposed to
there's cues that are $15,000,
$20,000
and up.
It's a really ornate and beautiful
and this is a lifetime.
Your adult lifetime of learning about
this.
Oh Man,
I've been immersed.
I started playing pool in 1990,
91.
90,
That's when I probably bought my first
pool cue.
What's a good.
What's a good pool cue for bumper pool?
My neighbors,
my neighbors had a bumper pool table
when I was a kid.
It was bad ass.
It's pretty stupid.
So stupid and dumb game.
The
older brother Mark,
he was the dominant one because he was
able to jump over the bumpers and get on
the other side.
Cheating.
Yeah.
The jumping is a very controversial
thing in the world of pool.
You're not allowed to jump.
Well,
you can butt attack jumping and then
there's bar table jumping.
Right?
Like when you play with people on a bar,
they think they're jumping in the pool
cue,
but what they're doing is they're
scooping under the cue ball with their
tip,
like they go under it and it sort of
makes the cue ball pop up in the air.
It's really like.
Yeah,
Ms Dot cueings.
What?
It's like the way you're supposed to
jump a ball has shoot down on it and
make it hop over.
Let's imagine,
have you seen this before?
Yeah,
that's an expense.
That's a Mcdermott.
Um,
it's called the excalibur or some shit
like that.
That's a pool cue.
Shit is,
but it isn't.
It's foolish.
It looks like a sickle that the grim
reaper comes to do away with.
Well,
this was a cute that was made a long
time ago.
It was made back in the fucking nineties
or something,
but that's not the most expensive pool
cue in the world.
Does that whole thing?
The q says it sold for $150.
That's not the most expensive shoe in
the world.
No,
no.
The most expensive cue in the world is
Gina.
Gina Q is actually right here in north
Hollywood.
That's,
they call it the most expensive in the
world.
It's that whole thing.
The Queue.
That's nonsense.
That's not to stand in a queue seat.
It's a acute,
that whole,
all the blades and everything like that.
What would you do with nonsense?
It's nonsense.
I'm telling you.
It's like having a car and you decided
to glue diamonds on it.
It's fucking stupid with calling the
wall.
Fuck up.
That cue weighs nine and a half pounds.
You know what a real cute ways.
A very heavy q,
very heavy is 21 ounces.
Like if you play with it,
like you find out that a pro plays with
20 miles could be like,
wow,
that's rarely a guy will play with it.
Twenty four rounds Cuban.
You're like,
wow,
that guy's crazy.
What was that thing?
Thing is nine and a half pounds a piece
of shit.
It's like the.
The women that get the gigantic hippity
hops for boobs getting bigger than that.
When you're like triples the boobs.
That's just not a real pool.
Cute.
What's the one in North Hollywood?
Well,
he makes.
His name is Ernie Cortez and he makes
all sorts.
I have one of his cues that's earning
right there.
Makes.
I mean he wasn't married to share.
No,
that's Sonny Bono.
You're an asshole.
I got in this podcast now I'm.
Ernie is A.
I mean he's like a real innovator in the
world of pool cues.
He makes beautiful,
beautiful.
That is beautiful.
But he had one that he made that was
filled with.
Like I thought,
I don't want to say what the material
was by believing the handle.
The handle was made out of solid ivory
and I'm thinking it had a gold and all
sorts of other shit in it,
but it went for half a million dollars.
It's worth a half million dollars,
but I think the deal is that he won't
sell it.
He's very wealth.
Whereas really well that offer.
Making sure.
Yeah.
His,
his pool cues like in Japan and also all
throughout Asia.
They're,
they're really revered,
like he sell his stuff anywhere.
His accuser very expensive on the
aftermarket too.
It makes them all by hand.
Like that kind of thing.
Well,
he designs them all and then he uses a
computer controlled machines.
They're called CNC machines to put
everything together and piece it so that
everything's perfect.
Wow.
Yeah.
But they're all like his designs and
that like three d printing.
No,
no.
It's,
um,
it's what it is,
is like you have a design and you put it
into this computer and you put the spa,
I don't know,
on 100 percent of the process,
but you put your specifications like how
wide you want in lays to be and they
make them exactly the same size and the
points fit exactly the same way.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's all super complicated stuff.
But the point is like if you were a guy
who wanted to buy a pool cue and you
just,
you know,
went to a website,
right?
You're,
you're lost.
You're lost.
Like me trying to buy one shot.
Yeah.
The fuck I'm looking at.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
It's weird.
This is good.
Wine though is good.
This is a scissors to big news.
I didn't know you spoke French to do we,
we see fit.
Paris is going crazy right now given
having these crazy riots know what's up.
Every time I think about visiting Paris,
there's some new shit that goes down
over there.
I know.
It's kind of feels like a little like a,
like a jewel box is about to explode.
All good man.
It's not good.
Is it workers?
What kind of riot?
Well,
the weird thing is everyone is riding is
wearing those reflective vests,
like see that?
Yeah.
They're wearing these yellow reflective
vests and lightened things on fire and
smashing store.
So like who is Gucci?
And these protestors have been going to
scroll back up.
So we got silent,
says 17 pictures.
Oh,
it's terrible.
And it keeps getting worse.
It keeps getting worse.
I mean it started November 17th when
French driver supporting yellow vests
led a demonstration apparently has to do
with oil prices rising.
Rising fuel prices 280,000
people.
Four people have died,
hundreds have been injured,
thousands of dollars with the property
has been damaged.
The protest started November 17th.
French driver sporting yellow vest led a
demonstration of 20,000
people across the country to push back
against the rising taxes on gas and
diesel.
A French President Emmanuel,
I love a nice microphone as part of his
many economic reforms and announced the
gas taxes early this year to minimize
Francis reliance on fossil fuels.
That's a fucking shitty way she handle,
you know,
reliance on fossil fuels.
You do the opposite.
You cunt face,
you don't charge people money.
You know,
you don't charge people extra money and
make it more expensive than they'll use
it unless you give them subsidies for
electric cars.
You stupid prick.
Yes.
Once you understand the American way,
you piece of shit.
I love talking about things.
I know nothing about.
What does it say?
Scroll back to where it was a the price
of fuel.
That's it.
Thirty cents a gallon.
They went crazy.
Thirty cents a gallon trying to kill
people.
Gas already costs about $7 per gallon.
What?
Fuck that.
So it's just going to break people's
backs and they drive you to.
The Bush was leaving office and they
jacked the fucking price of gas.
Way Up Dude.
But there's people that were panicking.
Yeah.
September 11th.
There's like lines everywhere because we
thought,
Ryan,
I just empty the price.
Didn't I don't think the price rattling
you went up.
Some places were charge like 25 bucks a
gallon they should go to jail.
But that's,
that's kind of insane that people used
to have riots like that when,
when we would spike and people couldn't
eat this,
they like,
oh my God,
that's a shitty little car.
Anyway,
I probably wanted to lie that empire
finally.
He's not even part of the protests.
He's just talking to me about this.
Somebody was telling me about this.
I was at a little kids.
Pardon me.
I was talking to one of the dads and he
was telling me about this,
uh,
thing that happened,
this,
I think it was in northern California.
It was a fire,
fucking might not have been.
Northern California was a fire.
And um,
initially they thought it was just a
fire,
but then the CEO and his vice president,
we're both of their houses caught fire.
So then they thought it was like an
attack on both people and then they
realized no,
it was a murder and one of the guys
killed the guy and his family and then
lit his house on fire and then went back
to his house and lit his own house on
fire to make it look like they were
going after.
Both of them and he's the only one that
survived.
Yeah.
Whoops.
This happened in New Jersey,
a guy in New Jersey.
Maybe that was.
It got murdered.
His whole family.
His own family.
Yeah.
And then lit the house on fire.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe I'm getting fucked up version of
the story.
I get drunk.
A kid parties to.
Oh,
it's the only way to go by family
massacred disguises a massive fire in
New Jersey.
Yeah,
that's it.
This is the story.
So make that a little larger police.
It says,
uh,
there was more of a brotherly bond
between Paul and Keith.
Yeah,
that's right.
Part of New Jersey on vacation together
and settled about 11 miles from each
other in the suburbs of New Jersey.
But two days before thanksgiving,
a horrific chain of events would forever
tear them apart.
Oh,
his brother.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
So I'm just getting a really fucked up
version of the story.
Paul,
how do you say that name?
Kenario.
Kenny.
Arrow became brothers killing his
youngest brother,
his sister in law and their children.
Oh,
this is
what's fucked up.
Like what?
What?
How does a guy go from never killing
anybody to killing a wife and daughter?
So he killed his brother and his
brother's whole family.
Oh my God.
I thought he killed his own.
Then he said his own home on fire with
his wife and daughter inside.
Tried to make it look as if the whole
family have been targeted.
His family got out of the home safely.
Can you imagine the panic?
Like what the fuck just murdered these
people.
You don't scroll,
Scroll,
go back,
go back.
You light your own house on fire and
you're like,
can you imagine like while your lighting
your house on fire thinking like the
intensity of this is gonna work.
I'm going to get out of this,
this,
this is where the plan goes and Poof,
it's really fun.
How does a person kill?
I mean,
I understand you're mad at a guy and you
fucking hate each other.
Fuck you.
And you start fighting and then you wind
up killing each other.
How do you kill his wife and daughters?
How do you do that?
What?
What switch goes on?
Like is he just trying to.
Yeah,
because he's just walking around.
We'll go back up.
It says it's killed.
His sister in law had said he's accused
accused of killing his younger brother,
his sister in law and their children.
Like how many children?
Like who he killed kids?
Yes.
So this is a guy who's never murdered
anybody just walking around.
Colts Neck Township,
New Jersey.
Yeah.
He's a businessman.
Probably never done anything really
major in his life.
Probably like,
was it a,
uh,
like a business meeting like two days
before with some guy.
What the fuck man?
Just living his life,
talking about the giants.
Like what the fuck?
What is that?
His wife and his two daughters.
Oh,
several twists in the case of that he
then allegedly said his own home on fire
with his wife and his daughters inside.
Did you not hear me say that?
I thought you were talking about his,
his brother's family?
No.
He killed his brother and his family.
Set the house on fire on fire.
Then lit his own house on fire to make
it look like he was being targeted.
I knew that,
but I didn't know his.
He had kids in his wife and his
daughters were inside.
Oh my God.
To try to make it look as if his whole
is being targeted.
His brother and him.
Oh my God.
His family got out of the home safely.
Wow.
Fucking unbelievable.
Think about his kids right now.
We're like,
what did that?
What?
Jesus Christ he.
Oh my God.
What am I just killed before sunrise?
Scroll up there.
Somewhere between midnight and 5:00
AM,
Paul.
Kenny Arrow was walking around his
brothers.
One point $5,000,000
colts,
neck home,
armed with a knife,
and a gun has been in front of the white
man's deadly confrontation.
Unfolded.
Paul fired multiple shots.
Striking Keith fucking when you got mad
at me for not following the story
clearly.
Did you feel like you could kill me?
No,
not yet.
I need more.
Need more than Jesus Christ.
He walked inside,
found his wife's,
found Keith's wife Jennifer.
He shot and stabbed her and then stabbed
their children.
Jesse.
Eleven and Sophia eight.
What the hell?
Then he took some documents instead of
fire in the basement.
What were they doing?
Like the fucking stabbed an eight year
old dude,
an eight year old girl in her sleep.
How to how to fuck to someone it would
say in her sleep.
Well,
it was 5:00
AM.
Doesn't matter man.
He's.
There's gunshots in the house.
The kids had gotten up.
Oh my God,
good Lord.
What a monster.
A monster.
What was this guy like the month before?
Like what the hell is that normal
looking house shit.
That is the normalist looking normal
house ever.
Do you believe that there isn't always a
presence of good and evil in the world
like that.
It's not just evil deeds.
What this guy did was evil,
but do you believe that there is a real
presence of evil?
That it's like a thing that takes over
people or takes over.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like,
like good and evil.
Is that more than just people's actions
or is it like a force of nature?
Is there a good force of nature and an
evil force of nature that is constantly
using people and using things as as a
catalyst or as a
okay instrument.
Let's break this down.
I don't think nature's the right way to
approach it because I don't think
there's good or evil in nature.
I think nature nature is actually far
more moral than humans are because
nature is just about survival.
Predators and prey and they kill things
and eat things,
but when animals in nature kill,
like with the called surplus killings
were wolves will kill like 18 elk and
not not eat them.
They're just.
They're just going on their instincts.
These things are there to be killed and
they can get them because they can't run
away.
Maybe it's fixed now or something like
that,
so they just can't help it.
They just tear them apart because their
instincts are drive them to kill because
that's how they survive.
That's other family survives.
They're killing and eating these elk and
this is just what they do and even if
they kill a bunch of them where they
can't eat them,
their instinct is to kill because that's
how they survive.
It's natural.
It's normal with humans will.
It's very different because with humans
there's consequences,
right?
And there's law and there's other humans
finding out.
So there's deception and then there's,
there's selfishness and there's the fear
of getting caught and then there's your
own your own survival instincts in terms
of like,
you don't want to get locked up in jail.
You don't want to get caught for
something.
So I think if I had a guess that this
guy didn't think he was going to kill
this guy's wife and family probably
didn't even think he was going to kill
this guy.
They probably got into a heated argument
and they,
they're stupid and he,
you know,
he's a Guinea.
He's,
that's my people.
They do stupid.
Your people to Ganny era.
They do stupid shit.
You know,
they're,
they're fiery people.
And those,
those fiery people.
I swore off Italian girls when I was 21
Italian girl.
Take a swing at me when I was 21,
I was like,
that's it for me.
I'm done.
I'm like,
I'm not hitting one back to fucking
cookie sum some look at some men and
some women are fucking crazy and I,
I believe in epigenetics and I see our
wacky.
My fucking own kids are.
What's epogen genetics?
Epigenetics.
Willis.
Let's Google it.
So I don't bust up the,
uh,
the actual definition,
but essentially it's a bill.
The way I'm using it is that there's
certain traits that are not just
environmental traits,
they're inherited traits and that you
hear it,
we'll pull it up.
Right?
The study,
the changes in organisms caused by the
modification of gene expression rather
than the alteration of the genetic code
itself.
This better was better words in that
there's better a better definition than
that.
The study of heritable changes in gene
expression.
There you go.
Active versus inactive genes that do not
involve changes to the underlying DNA
sequence.
A change in the phenotype without a
change in the Geno type,
which in turn affects how cells read the
jeans a great.
Now I know less about it.
I think there's traits,
and this is,
this is a very,
um,
this is a very controversial yet I'm
very,
a fascinating field of study because
what they're doing is they're,
they're finding out that children that
are twins that are separated by,
you know,
when they're babies,
they go into different foster homes and
they're raised by different families,
have incredibly,
remarkably similar characteristics.
Lives,
loves and desires,
like what they're interested in,
incredibly simple and they're suspecting
that a lot of the,
like you,
we are a combination of nature and
nurture.
I think that's safe to say and I think
that there you certainly a lot of things
happen to kids when they're young that
shaped their life,
whether it's physical or sexual abuse,
whether it's exposure to violence or
whether it's positive things like love
and encouragement and inspiration,
but there's certain information I think
that's transferred from the parent to
the child while the child is in the womb
and when,
during,
during the conception of the child.
I think there's traits that come from
the father and traits that come from the
mother.
Biological,
biologically.
And I think this is undeniable across
species.
And I think this is why dogs like my dog
has no fucking idea who his parents are.
He doesn't give a shit.
He's like,
he's not looking for.
Is that on 23 dot?
Exactly.
I grabbed that leash and he's like,
we run into there and his.
What are you doing,
Jay Movie?
Watched it yet?
The three identical strangers.
No,
I haven't,
but it's about this exact thing,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
did you watch it?
I've started to like watch the trailers
and stuff,
but it was a good waiter to come on
Netflix.
It's on Netflix.
Yeah.
Your dog's not like wonder what my dad's
doing now.
Why did he leave me?
Yeah.
Awesome.
Hopes gathering in the woods.
No,
but he's got certain instincts,
like you lifts up his leg to Piss on
things,
smells things like the end.
And he chases squirrels.
Like there's,
there's things that are in.
He's a retriever,
right?
He's a golden retriever.
So he brings things back.
I mean if I had pit bulls before and
they'll bring things back,
you got to teach them.
They don't want to bring things back and
they definitely don't want to let go,
but they want to do is play tug of war
with shit like.
But he lets things go and it's natural
for him.
That soft mouth.
Yes.
I have a black lab.
Does the same thing.
They hold things gently because they're
used to retrieving ducks and animal and
pheasants that people shoot.
That's what they were raised for.
Yeah.
So he brings things back.
Like when I get him up in the morning,
right?
He stays in this little room and when I
get up in the morning at seven to take
my kids to school and all that stuff,
when I open up the door he whines like
crazy.
He gets crazy,
wags his tail.
So.
But the first thing he does is pick up a
toy.
He picks up stuff to him when it comes
to me with a stuffed animal in his
mouth.
Like this
is not something that we taught him,
but this is something.
And Golden retrievers all around the
world doing the same exact thing.
Yep.
All around the world.
All around the same exact thing.
There's certain traits.
Yeah,
and I believe that Italians,
my,
my people,
my people.
I'm not saying this about.
Yeah.
And Yours too.
I'm mostly Italian.
They're savage folk.
This is just a fact,
man.
Just a fact.
There's,
there's a streak,
a streak.
It goes back to the Romans.
That's what I really,
absolutely 100 percent believe that.
Um,
I think there are certain civilizations
that have a longer history of being
civilized and,
and less violence.
And I think when you are,
were you dealing with folks that have in
a real history of violence in their
culture and that this translates
generation to generation and transfers
down to the children.
And I think this guy is part of that.
I mean it's like there's not,
it's not a coincidence that the Italian
mob,
so ruthlessly brutal.
What did the Russian mob.
So yeah,
sleep brutal.
Excuse me,
know for sure.
There's definitely that part of it.
And then there's the other part of it
that,
like you said,
there's a,
there's the nurture part of it.
Who knows what was going on in this
guy's life that you know.
Okay,
so here we have two Italian brothers,
right?
Yeah.
Raised the same way.
Italian hot streak.
All those things together.
One brother decided to burn the house
down and slow to the family.
The other,
an Italian guy didn't have that in his
to do list,
but not necessarily because I don't know
if they planned it out or if he did just
because.
I mean he had a knife on him and a gun.
Maybe there's one of those crazy asshole
that brought a knife and a gun
everywhere.
Who the fuck knows?
But they were in business together and
you know,
people in business together and it's
not.
They get crazy and they get real
resentful and you know,
they think one person's not doing their
fair share.
One person fucks up a deal or one person
costing them money.
And now who knows?
But how the fuck did he kill each other?
So there's no.
I have a baby man.
How do you stab an eight year old
daughter?
Well,
you take it in your hand.
Yeah,
I have no idea.
But the Italians also like wine,
more wine,
please soon as drunk give you one of
these zero percent alcohol Heineken's.
He's supposed to be the most delicious.
I've never had it.
And we'll try one of these.
I supposed to be the most delicious,
nonalcoholic beer.
Not recommended.
They said that if you want to try,
I'll try nonalcoholic beer.
That doesn't suck.
Get this a Heineken zero.
Zero.
So Heineken's zero.
It's supposed to be the shit.
Hmm.
Tastes like Heineken does.
There's literally no difference.
Pretty damn good for nonalcoholic beer.
Doesn't have that weird.
I'm lying to myself.
Funk to it.
Yeah.
It doesn't have that a weird after
taste.
If I was a junkie,
I would not want to try great opiate.
Free heroin.
It tastes just like.
It just seems like it'd be a smart move,
but alcoholics will drink nonalcoholic
beer.
Walk into a liquor store by this non
alcoholic guy.
But you literally at the gate of Hell
and the,
the,
the fucking demons are reached and
you're like,
no,
no.
Thank you.
Zero zero.
Let me just test myself or clean or cool
with taking cbd.
Like is that a good question?
Well,
the marijuana thing is different because
I think for the vast majority of human
beings,
obviously there's a lot of biological
diversity,
but for the vast majority of human
beings,
I do not think that marijuana is
physically addictive.
I think it's entirely possible that for
some people it is,
but I think for the vast majority of
people it is not physically addictive.
It's more psychologically addictive.
So I think it's a different thing.
So if they're taking cbd,
what they're.
I mean it depends on how they're taking.
If they're rolling up a CBD joint,
CBD,
which is a little extra,
do they do that for sure,
but doesn't some cbd have a little bit
of thc to go with that?
Some of it.
Well,
this shed has the tiniest amount of
alcohol,
his alcohol free,
but I think it's like what are the
calories?
Zero,
zero point zero,
four alcohol free beer with natural
flavoring.
Do you know a Heineken's one of the few
beers that you can drink if you are a
celiac?
It does not.
Have wheat,
it's not a wheat based beer,
so if you're gluten you can drink
heineken,
eh,
maybe not if you're Celiac,
but definitely if you're gluten free,
that's not bad.
Yeah,
I like it.
That's not bad at all.
It's not bad,
but calories of standard.
Half the calories of a standard beer.
So those other calories,
just pure alcohol I guess.
Yeah,
right.
I wonder if there's like a,
you know,
um,
there's one episode of the Opiod,
Anthony Show.
I remember this.
Oh my God,
I forgot about this.
We gave this gal who she had this.
Uh,
I think it was her name was stocker
patty.
I think that was.
I remember we gave this crazy.
You know how radio shows have these
regulars that always come to the studio?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well they gave this one gal,
I'm a breath strip,
like a standard listerine breast trip
and this was back in the day when I used
to get pot breath strips that would,
they would fuck you up so hard.
I remember I gave a half a one to
Thompson girl and we flew to Florida do
gigs together and by the time we landed
it's like,
dude,
I want to tell you something I almost
didn't make.
It was almost telling these people to
turn this flight around.
Started freaking out half of a breast
job.
We'll put you in an alternative
dimension.
It was so strong,
so we gave this gal a regular breast
trip.
There's a video of it online.
It's like an hour long.
They don't vet had no.
I had no wheat and no red.
Gave her this breath strip and then he
proceeded to like to talk to her and she
was talking about hi.
She was and she's so funny.
She couldn't go anywhere,
but we all knew that she was sober.
She was.
When you're a person who's like a whack
pack or from this high,
there's something is an issue that's not
being resolved.
Yes.
That makes it hard to listen to frankly
is not a widow and actualized human
being.
That would be the table.
This is not an actualized human being.
Someone who's got their shit together
though,
they're reading self help books and
fucking getting up at five and doing
yoga.
No,
no,
no.
It just trying to get through the day.
They're barely getting through.
I found this thing that makes them.
That they cling to.
Yeah.
Those characteristics are fascinating to
me because you see,
you find them in other things.
Would you be those characteristics of
these people that find something to
belong to and then they become a thing.
They become a part of that thing.
You would find those people at pool
halls.
You'll find those people at martial arts
places.
You find those people that hang out at
comedy clubs.
It's like they're a little off,
but they find a thing.
Yeah.
That becomes the thing that they do all
the time.
Even if they're not like the comedian,
they'll hang out at the comedy so we
know those folks for sure,
and I don't.
I totally get it.
I mean,
that's community.
Yes,
like just wanting to belong somewhere.
We all want that thing.
Just that's where I go and I know those
faces
and they know me and maybe I'm not
totally a part of it,
but I can go to the pool hall and yes,
feel like I went,
I was wanted
close.
The pool hall was a perfect place for
that because it was a hangout like a lot
of people weren't playing,
so if you had like three or four tables
going there,
so three or four tables would be like a
six or eight people playing pool,
but there might also be five or six
people just hanging out.
Maybe playing cards,
maybe be just buying coffee and maybe
ordering a sandwich or something like
that and just sitting there eating.
It's important.
I was reading a whole article about that
by David Brooks the other day and he was
saying that that's economically we're
richer than we've ever been as a country
and even in the last couple of years,
like poor people,
like everyone's standard of living has
gone up.
Which I wasn't really clear on.
I thought that only the rich people were
doing.
We're were getting Richard,
but everybody was kind of being lifted
up,
but we're unhappier than ever before and
the life expectancy is lower than ever
before and we're killing ourselves at
rates that are higher than ever before,
and he was saying that it's that lack of
community that we don't go to church
anymore.
We don't belong to those things that
gave us meaning everyday in our town and
used to go to church and you'd go to the
pool hall.
You go to that,
you need that sense of belonging and
work is a big part of it and people now
are in this gig economy and they're
working uber,
they're working seamless,
they're doing different things.
They're isolated,
they're by themselves and I'm working
with other people and it's.
He really believes that it's that lack
of community and that lack of
institutions is why we're very,
very unhappy as a,
as a country right now.
It makes sense to me.
It makes sense to me as a person who's a
part of a vital community.
As a comedian.
I was talking to Jeff Ross was here the
other day with Dave attell and one of
the things that he said that really
struck with me,
he said,
I almost feel like I'm a comedian more
than I'm an American.
Am I going to comedian first?
American second?
I was like,
yeah,
you,
if you were at the airport and you know,
you run into Dave attell or whoever it
is,
like,
it's like there's a light upon them.
It comes down from heaven.
Exactly.
Hey,
just embrace them.
That's why I always,
I would always get suspicious of comics
who didn't embrace me.
Like as soon as you home,
like I was like,
there's something weird with it.
Yeah.
Something like horror comics that don't
have any comic friends.
Yeah.
It's very weird.
Fucking real strange and they're always
super selfish.
Okay.
It's,
yeah.
I can't even figure out exactly what it
is,
but I'm just like,
I know that's not one of the good ones.
Yeah.
Especially if someone's like a
successful comedian that's really weird.
Like you have the opportunity to hang
out with some of the most fun people in
the world.
You're a peer of theirs and you give
them a pass.
It's like family.
It's like,
no.
Oh,
I did this gig in,
in Colorado once and just by chance it
was like this corporate thing.
And there was another comic on the bill
who I won't mention.
And I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
We're in the middle of like nowhere.
And at least there's another comedian
here.
He did his set split.
Didn't talk to me just like there was
no.
I was like,
your dog,
like,
Hey,
let's play.
Let's just split.
I was like,
all right,
that guy's weird that guys,
there's something and I am.
It's true.
It's common now than it was back in the
day.
And this was another thing that I talked
about with the,
with jeff and Dave as we were talking
about comradery,
that there's,
um,
there's less competition now than there
ever was before.
Because before there was only a limited
number of tonight's show slots.
There was a limited number of sitcoms it
could be on.
And that's what everybody wanted.
Everybody wanted their own Sitcom.
Everybody wants to be on the tonight
show.
And there are very few of those very few
and everybody was competing for these
very limited slots and there's very few
hbo specials there was,
was not,
there wasn't a lot and there was a lot
of us and so it led to a lot of like
jealousy,
a lot of clawing and scratching.
You can see thanks to many things.
Thanks to the Internet,
thanks to youtube initially then
podcasts and then Netflix.
It seems like the world is our oyster.
There's so much you have to do is put
out good content.
Totally.
And you could have your own audience and
he could have his own audience.
She could have hers and all exist
without having to poach each other's
audiences.
Yeah.
And
Leno.
I promote.
Look in the beginning of.
If you're listening to this on youtube,
it's not on it because it's something
that I do in the beginning of the audio
version of it,
but I.
I'm always talking about people's
specials that are out like the now the
bumping mic special.
Would Dave and Jeff Ross is out now.
They're not paying me to say that
Netflix is not the me to say that the
special with the Christina [inaudible]
special,
they're not paying me to say that I'm
saying that because these people are all
my friends and I want them to prosper
when everybody knew I want them to.
I think they're great and I want
everybody to know that this is great
stuff and if you.
If you're a fan of comedy,
I want to help you find.
It's like I want to be that guy in the
wine store going,
hey,
you want to see an $18 bottle of wine?
They'll knock your digging in the dirt.
It's Joey.
Nobody knows about,
but you're going to love it.
Well,
more people know about joey now than
ever before.
Enough.
Not Enough.
Yeah.
No,
I know he's the best ever.
I've never.
I've never seen anybody that makes me
laugh harder.
I don't know if I.
If I enjoy him as much as I want,
as much as I enjoy how much you enjoy
him,
it really is such a great thing.
Just watching you guys when he's going
off and you're laughing at him,
it's just,
it's like I could watch that all day.
I feel so thankful.
He's so real.
He's such A.
I mean,
he's just one of those.
So real.
Especially if I have a buzz.
I got about a couple of drinks.
Smoke a little weed.
Now Watch Joey.
I'm so thankful.
There's a guy like that out there.
In my opinion,
he's leader of the charge because he's
the most reckless and wild and and even
more so now.
Now that he did that,
Netflix special,
all my God.
Go,
go see him.
People.
He is a fucking monster right now.
He's like,
he's peaking.
He's better than he was before and he
was the best before.
No,
it's such a great thing.
Like when you go to any club and then
you come in and you just see whatever
random people are there.
You know,
my wife was a comedian before we had
kids and the first thing she wants to
ask,
she asked when I come back as who?
Who was there?
Who did you say?
And it's like,
oh,
he's so Steve Byrne,
I saw the whatever,
and she's like,
oh,
she wants,
because she doesn't,
she's not part of the community like she
is,
but she doesn't get the visit.
So it's like she misses that sense and
we're very lucky to have that as grown
men to be able to like walk into this
very fun community that you're a part
of.
It gives you,
meaning,
it gives you a sense of,
of belonging.
And that's what a lot of people don't
have nowadays.
It's very,
uh,
according to David Brooks,
that's the reason for everybody's
malaise,
I think.
Let me something too though.
I think it's weird living in places
where you don't know your neighbors.
That's fucking weird.
I mean,
yeah,
Norton was telling me that he lives in
this big apartment building in New York
City and I think he,
I mean,
it's got to be hundreds of people living
in that building,
these huge,
huge building.
Yeah,
no worries.
No anybody.
We're here.
It says no,
it doesn't know anybody.
He says he tried to say hi to his
neighbor.
They looked at him like he's a fucking
murderer.
Nobody's friendly to anybody.
So weird.
They're like,
you're too loud.
Stop making noise.
That's what everybody does to people.
Bang on the door,
banging on the floor,
banging in the room.
Conflict.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing and it's weird,
you know,
my,
my youngest wants to go to church and
how old?
13.
And because friends what does,
maybe she has more of a,
she's more of a sensitivity and like she
knows there's something other than
there's something spiritual going on.
Mushrooms,
I think that might've been what kicked
the whole thing on.
And uh,
and she's just,
she's searching a little bit and she
wants that.
She likes being able to sit someplace in
a and we go and it's not like when I was
a kid,
like when I was a kid and we were
Catholic,
the place was packed.
Like you couldn't find parking.
It's like,
it was like,
it was a big deal that my father would
be like,
we're going early,
come on,
get out of the house.
We got to get a spot.
I'm not walking from the back.
And it was like a big thing.
Now it's like you kind of roll up,
it's half full and there's nobody there
and it's,
you know,
of course the Catholic Church has a lot
of problems and.
But every but every.
What do you mean by problem?
But all these religions have had a
little,
a little kerfuffle.
Have a lot like the Catholic church.
No,
the Catholic church is the worst.
It's the worst.
But the.
I know,
but don't let me get sides.
But the,
the thing is we know so much now and
we're able to see that all these
institutions are flawed,
that there's problems with all of them.
We used to be,
people used to think,
my grandmother just thought churches the
best and this is the best one.
They didn't ask questions.
Now we know everything and we know that
all these institutions are flawed.
And I think we're making the mistake
that you can't be a part of a political
party.
You can't be a part of a community.
You can't be a part of the thing if it's
not perfect,
but that's not a way to live.
You gotta kind of be a little ignorant
if you're going to show up,
you got to kind of not be ignorant,
but allow things to be flood
or start a new one,
go on.
I mean the the right way to address the
issues of a flawed institution and not
just accept them,
but to try to create a new institution
that doesn't have as many flaws.
I mean that's what we.
That's not what we did,
but our founding fathers did.
When they established the United States
of America,
the idea was to establish a place where
you have an experiment in self
government and that's never existed
before in the world and this is what the
United States represents to the rest of
the world outside of us.
I mean this is what we,
again,
I keep saying we,
it's not we,
but with the people that established the
United States did was they broke the
mold as to how a world superpower or a
country.
It wasn't a super power that exists,
but how a country could exist and then
that country.
I mean,
I don't think it's a coincidence that
Adam just a couple hundred years that
country emerged the greatest superpower
of the world's ever known.
I think that freedom allows
unprecedented activity in terms of
innovation,
in terms of creativity and not being
suppressed and not being in total fear
for your life,
for any form of descent.
So any,
and this is.
This goes back to not just religion but
any sort of any group,
any,
any group that's in control of any sort
of a situation.
As soon as you suppress all the other
people,
you limit their ability to contribute
and this is what is existed all
throughout Europe and would existed all
throughout Asia,
all throughout the rest of the world.
Yeah.
When the United States came along and
then when the United States came along,
all the sudden you have this
unprecedented development and growth and
this one place where people are allowed
to be free.
Where we support free expression.
We we support free religious freedom of
religion and we separate church and
state and this is one of the reasons why
these things are so important.
So when you get like religious
fundamentalists Wackos that say this
country was founded on Christian values,
that doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if you're a peaceful
Muslim,
if you're a peaceful Buddhist,
if you're a peaceful mormon,
whatever the fuck it is,
we should all embrace each other.
We should allow each other 100 percent
freedom.
And as soon as someone starts
restricting that freedom and restricting
people's ability to express themselves,
you run into real problems because then
you don't let these things play out in
their order.
You don't let ideas play out where
people get to examine those ideas and
change.
Like look,
if you look at some of the more
suppressive areas of the Middle East,
the real problem is that these people
live not just as many real problems,
but one of the real problems is these
people live in fear.
So there's no real freedom of
expression.
And there's also this real desire for
conformity is real desire to establish
that you are a part of the group that is
one of the good ones that's going to
abide by the rules and you are going to
show everyone else that you were a part
of this group,
whether it means throwing gay people off
buildings or throwing rocks at women's
shelters,
all that stuff.
I was just gonna say like your life
actually depends on you conforming.
Yes.
I was with my friend the other day who's
gay and he was saying that he just
stopped the chest one.
Just come on,
come on,
shout it out.
And it really,
how close is close?
Comes over your house.
So close.
Whoa.
I didn't realize he can't go to half of
the planet as an open gay man.
Oh yeah.
He can't go to Russia.
He can't go to all of the Middle East.
There's parts of age like they will kill
you if you're gay in those areas.
Yeah,
I mean talk about.
I mean,
what's going to make a city flourish
then gay people coming in with bold
ideas and let's go.
I mean,
I saw them change parts of New York like
it was nobody's business.
Well,
and also I think that like the,
the.
What's great about gay folks is when gay
folks are embraced and they're allowed
to be themselves,
oh my God,
I can express that,
and then you get to see that,
like there's a.
there's such a giant spectrum of the way
people behave and think and the things
that they love,
and if you don't allow people to express
their position on that spectrum,
then you don't even know it exists.
Then you create all sorts of deviance
because you're forcing them into some
unnatural pattern,
which is one of the things that I think
about the Catholic church.
I think part of the problem is that
these people are suppressed sexually,
like incredibly suppressed,
not just suppressed in terms of their,
whether they're homosexual or
heterosexual,
but there's no sex.
You're not allowed to have any sex,
right?
Yeah.
So how's it going to come out?
It's fucking insane.
It's insane
denial of the fact that you need to
drink water
and it's so upsetting because I'm really
kind of searching a little bit because I
was raised Catholic and I did like going
to have what she has.
I did like going and sitting in the Pew
on Sunday was different from the other
days and I asked,
I got to hear people talk about being
nice to each other and I got to see the
people from my town who you saw running
around,
but now they're just sitting there
quietly and praying.
There was goodness to it and they went
out and fed the homeless.
There was good stuff that came from it
and she wants that.
I get that.
And now you're sitting in an institution
though the,
you know,
the backstory of what's going on.
It's,
you know,
how do you sit there?
How do you sit there said
to her last night,
maybe we should just go to yoga,
satisfy your spiritual side with wacky
to men.
I know.
Look,
I go to a Bikram Yoga,
I go to hot yoga,
hot yoga,
and that guy,
I don't think he's allowed to come in
this country.
No,
he's not.
The guy who made big room now know that
guy not think he's best case.
He.
He got a little rapey.
Well,
he definitely got a little.
He took advantage of his privilege,
his position,
our.
Well,
yeah,
I guess you could say power,
but the reverence that people had
towards him,
they felt like he was a guru and so he
would get these girls alone and he would
make them suck tank or whatever,
but I think per seat,
now this,
I'm getting this very dangerous waters,
but I was having a conversation with a
woman who is a.
she's actually an instructor and she
said,
listen,
that guy is definitely creepy,
but let me tell you something.
A lot of those girls not only knew what
he was about,
but they wanted to be with him.
They want him to be with him because of
his power and because he represented
something special to them and then when
he just shot a load in their mouth and
kicked him to the curb,
then they became angry and decided they
were molested.
They went into it willingly.
I do not know if she's accurate or
inaccurate.
I was not there and I'm not a woman,
but I do know that people have like a.
I remember women throwing,
throwing themselves,
but making it very clear that they were.
They had deep admiration for my martial
arts instructor when I was,
when I was a young kid and I was a
practicing taekwondo.
I remember these women.
They were so in awe of my martial arts
instructor because he represented a
master of something that they were
deeply enamored by it and I think that's
also what happens with these yoga
people.
Yeah,
it's seductive.
It's seductive,
and also with something like that,
it's very physical and mental and
spiritual.
It's sexual,
sexual like it is.
Look,
I don't.
I've never had any sex with anybody in
my class,
but I'm telling you when everybody's in
there sweating and,
and almost naked,
I'm wearing these little fucking shorts
and the girls were wearing these little
shorts and,
and the teacher goes around and she like
calls you out.
It's like,
oh,
she likes me.
Yes,
I can undo
Stan.
How some of those people get intimate
with each other after this is all over
because they're,
they're so close to being naked
wedding together and your friend is
right.
Uh,
in that,
there were some women I'm sure who
wanted to be with him,
but he's not dismissing any rap shit
either,
but it's his responsibility because he
has the power and knows what he's
wielding like in a workplace kind of
thing.
It's up to you to be the one who puts
the brakes on it.
That's where it gets interesting.
He does not seem to think that he does
have any responsibility at all for the
people that are working for him teaching
these classes.
And like he was,
he did this hbo documentary.
It was fucking,
they did this hbo interview about him.
It was so ridiculous.
This is the big guy.
Yeah.
He goes,
the other women that will pay $1,000,000
for one drop of my sperm.
He says this tv,
you can find the video.
So he's fully aware.
He's fucking crazy.
He's fully aware of his crazy.
Yeah,
he was.
He was dismissing the idea that he would
ever sexually assault anyone.
He's like,
why would I do that when these women
that will pay $1,000,000
for one drop of my.
Well,
it wasn't.
Why wasn't?
Yeah,
it wasn't brought.
Bryant Gumbel wasn't there.
I think they're discussing it.
We're discussing this comment.
You go on to see the guy because he
looks like a.
because he said the comment to a woman
and she was like this.
She was like,
what in the fuck did you say hbo shows
various crammer breaks down million
dollars.
Sperm Interview Interview Shit that you
said.
There's some shit that you say where
people go,
wait,
what the fuck?
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
There's some things that are calling it
that you would call beyond the Pale.
Well,
I love.
I love just seeing pictures.
You hear these stories,
then you see him,
he's like,
you're like grandpa.
He's like,
oh,
loose skin,
and he's balding and.
But that's the thing.
It's like when you're in a power of a
powerful position like that,
he's very spiritual and people will pay
$1,000,000.
What does it say from being circumspect?
A real sport?
Uh,
the 70 year old went off on a rant
claiming 500 women a day wanted to sleep
with him for,
have committed suicide over his charms,
and people would pay $1,000,000
for a drop of his sperm.
CNL Irish.
If you lived in that world,
I would just shoot loads every day and
then retire.
If you,
if you just drank eight.
A lot of zinc.
Zinc and like what makes loads?
Oysters.
Celery.
Yeah.
Is that Vegan nonsense propaganda pieces
adds to the pop.
Who tells you that?
The salary people.
That's like some fucking salary lobby.
No,
it's true.
Salary does.
How do you know?
I read,
I read something.
Porn people,
right?
Salary.
Salary was Jamie got here.
Oh,
here it is.
The most beautiful,
famous,
rich women in the world.
If have to sleep with women and have to
sleep,
you know,
by thousand garden every day she tells
in women a day one to sleep with,
you commit suicide.
Four of them.
You're saying that for different women,
for different ornament each killed
themselves because you wouldn't have sex
one time.
Why I am doing it.
Women People's been $1,000,000
for one drop of my sperm million dollar
in day.
Every drop.
That idiot or dumb to believe those
trash to women or the trash.
Yeah.
I begged him pump trash and give them
life.
Oh my God.
Seventy years old.
He looks pretty good for a 70 year old
selling all that loads.
Oh my God.
I don't last very long.
I gotta to get it dry up real quick.
Yeah,
they get gross.
Do you know man?
Oh Man.
Yeah.
So that spiritual thing like that,
but that's.
Yeah.
It's like the problem with it is you're
still an animal,
right?
So the animal.
It's like we were talking about before
with the wolves gone,
these surplus kills and they kill all
these elk and they don't eat them again.
Wyoming.
There was a recent issue,
there was 18 elk that were killed by
wolves in these surplus killings is a
real tragic.
Yeah.
These walls can't help themselves.
It's just their instincts.
So his instincts as a man,
he has instincts to procreate,
right?
His instincts to respond to women that
are sexually attracted to him,
and he teaches these classes in front of
hundreds and thousands of people and
everybody loves and adores him.
Soon he fucked up twisted brain.
Everything that he said there made
sense.
My favorite part of it was that woman,
Andrea,
when she,
when she clarified.
So you're saying,
you're saying that for women have
committed to it like,
I want this motherfucker has to be clear
on this nonsense.
I like how she's there is.
She doesn't even change her expressions.
She's just like.
So you're saying?
Yeah.
I mean,
look at that girl right now.
He's standing on top of a woman's hips
as she's bent over backwards.
That girl is like,
he wants me.
He standing over me.
I've taken a lot of yoga classes.
Nobody ever stood on my hips.
Now,
hey bro,
but I do like it when you're doing yoga
and they come over and they like push
your legs down and you're like,
yeah,
well it's a little depressing.
Oh Shit.
I just spilled assistant.
I spelled wine.
Leave it there bro.
Let it sink in.
That's good for the,
the Patina.
I'm learning those,
those terms,
the Patina.
So there.
So when you're in the church,
the Church of Yoga,
home or real and you're abusing your
power,
that's a different animal because you're
dealing abusing with children.
It's a totally different animal and then
we've taken six year olds and abusing
them.
It's a different animal.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like there's levels to this
shit,
right?
Like the guy killing his brother is
horrific to me.
The guy killing his
brother's wife,
more horrific guy killing his brother's
wife and then kids.
Impossible.
Demonic.
It's like what you were saying earlier,
like do you believe in good or evil?
I don't know if I believe in it,
but if it did exist,
it exists in the minds of men exist in
that time,
you know,
it's a no or.
Yeah,
but you know what I,
I had this bit that I did on my last
special and it was about men's rights
groups and I was trying to figure out a
way to say this and make it be funny,
but it's so true that I said men commit.
Most of the murderer men commit.
Most of the rape men cause all the war.
This is,
these are facts like the most horrific
things in our life,
our war,
murder,
rape,
those are the most horrific things in
all of life means death pales in
comparison and I think men steal more
than women too,
but that that's the evil.
This is.
If there was a demon and the demon came
down to earth and there's only three
things that it could get you to do,
it would get you to rape,
murder and caused war.
Right?
So if a demon was real demon would be
men.
I get,
I,
I said this as a joke that I get
feminists,
like in the special.
I was like,
I get it.
If I was a feminist,
I'd be one too.
I'm like,
I can't be one as a man because they're
not real,
because like male feminists,
like they're just tricksters.
They're just like,
show me a male feminist that can pick up
heavy things and run really fast.
You don't exist this,
you have a limited parameter where
you're allowed to be a male feminist,
but yeah,
but I get it,
but when I look at the actions of men,
if you're an objective person,
you take yourself out of the human race
and you look at all,
all human beings and you look at the
horror that meant not that women haven't
done awful shit and falsely accused
people and killed their kids and women
have done all those things.
Sure.
Some women,
some.
But the vast majority of horrors I've
been
had been committed by men.
Yeah,
I know.
It's a very primitive,
uh,
a way to look at the world that there's
good and evil and it exists in these
certain ways.
That's good.
That's all good.
All right.
But hit it.
That Toki crazy.
I'm worried that I won't be funnier
after I do this.
Let's see me pick up the slack.
Did you like Elon Musk?
You're a Goddamn parent.
Pioneer.
Jamie's going to go deeper.
Jamie's going for three,
I think is that Jamie has hip problem.
If you,
uh,
if you see a video of the floor,
she hits the wrong button.
Like biggie smalls over there in a cloud
of.
What's amazed.
Amazing to me is that this is now a 100
percent legal here.
It's still not federally.
Right?
Well,
that's what was funny about the Eland
thing when Elan smoked it here.
It was like,
it's totally legal.
It's totally okay.
But in everyone's minds they're still
like,
no,
it's not.
Yeah.
Well they need to let it go.
And this is why.
No,
I didn't
need to let it go.
We're on your side.
You know,
I'm,
I'm on,
I'm on like the,
the,
the good people of government,
law enforcement,
fire department,
military,
the good people.
If I'm on your side,
man.
Yeah.
And I'm a stoner.
I'm on your side.
I'm on your side a thousand million
percent.
And making it legal actually helps all
that because now you don't have to go
out and fight these phony war is against
it.
It doesn't just do that.
It makes people more compassionate and
it makes people look.
It's like everything else you can abuse
beating off.
You know,
I remember when I was a million dollars
a drop $1,000,000
for one drop of my sperm.
You know,
if you're a person that gets obsessed
with masturbation,
like you could ruin your life.
Yeah.
There's people that are legitimate porn
addictions where they watch porn eight,
10 hours a day and they can't stop.
Right.
This is like everything.
Yeah.
I think you can ruin yourself with
sugar.
You can ruin yourself with food.
You can ruin yourself with,
with laziness.
You can.
You can get into a habit where you just
can't get up.
Yeah.
You know,
you can get into a comfort zone.
We just want to take baths.
All right.
People do shit like.
Yeah.
No,
I know.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's.
Did Roseanne say she did that after all
of her bullshit went down,
she has gotten the bath all the time.
Drank wine.
Was that this is their safe space.
I apologize,
I wasn't
so um,
so anyway,
I know it's a very basic way.
I mean we've been talking about good and
evil since the time of the men were able
and women were able to,
you know,
write and philosophize and.
But it,
I don't know,
it just seems to me lately like I've see
it feels to me like evil and good is
actually a force that we're struggling
with and I know there's,
I know like some people would say that's
kind of a primitive way of thinking,
but I do kind of feel like,
uh,
it actually is a very real,
tangible thing.
And that.
What makes you think this,
your personal feelings?
Is it based on like your intuition?
Like what is it?
I,
yeah,
it's intuition.
It's like a vibe.
It's like a,
it's just like a maybe because I'm
showing up at church and kind of like
searching a little bit.
Myself and I,
I am very much about good people doing
good things and I've just been kind of
conscious of it,
but then there's always like these,
this rise of evil that comes up like all
of a sudden white supremacists are.
These riots are these horrible things
against people in different parts of the
world and it's.
It seems like it's an ongoing struggle
look almost like why hasn't caught up
yet to the way you look at the world
where a lot of people look at the world.
A lot of people look at the world like,
like if Tom Papa,
if you were in charge,
and if you had to push all the buttons,
that would sort of decide how people
behaved.
If that was a possible thing.
Of course you'd have one of the first
thing you do is eliminate all the
violence and all the horrors of the
world.
Yeah.
And if.
And then also,
I'm sorry to cut you off,
but you also see the.
All those hires are done by these men
and stuff.
Who when you sit in like kind of analyze
them and they've been the victims of a
lot of things and there's like genetic
victimization and social and it's like,
so where's that coming from?
Why are these,
this kid that could have been okay ends
up in this life of crime and ended up
murdering somebody and where's that
coming from?
Is this just a genetic mutation or is
there like a force of good and evil?
I think we're still.
We're still dealing with the echoes of
the past.
That's what I really firmly believe and
I think also the way maybe you and I are
having this conversation the way a lot
of people are having these conversations
today just like us,
but basically the same sort of rational
people sitting around with no agenda
going,
why does this exist?
Why does all the horrors of life?
Why?
Why is all this injustice?
Why is that there?
Yeah.
I think this is it.
We haven't been here that long.
I just really think that that's real and
I think we need to absorb that much
better.
Our time spent in modern civilization
versus the time of life on earth is a
joke.
The time on life,
on earth and in relationship to the time
of the universe is a joke.
Right?
The numbers are insane.
I can't understand that.
We literally were monkeys just a couple
of weeks ago.
Right.
But the bit that I have my act about the
United States being founded in 1776,
that's three people go behind her.
That's three people go really is.
Yeah.
That's nothing.
So three people go.
People were these creatures that had to
make fire to stay warm.
They didn't have electricity.
They didn't have engines.
Yeah,
they.
They made boats at a trees and they use
the wind to drift across the ocean while
staring at the stars with the fucking
gigantic harp looking thing.
Right.
What was the thing?
A sextant?
Yeah.
That thing that they use to figure out
where the other ones are.
She had a trust that these motherfuckers
had mapped out the universe.
Well,
that was.
You could make it across the ocean and a
lot of people died of scurvy along the
way.
Like fuck man,
that's crazy.
Not long ago,
so God damned recent.
Yeah.
When I was listening to Dan Carlin's
hardcore history,
one of the best podcasts ever to be,
I don't know if you're so good,
but he has this thing on the mon goals
called the wrath of the cons and what
freaked me out is not just how crazy
that world was back then and what
unbelievable damage and destruction the
Mongols created and how they just
conquered empires just moved across the
world,
killed millions and millions of people,
but it was really fucked up was I think
Google does to make sure I'm not wrong.
I think that was only like 1200 BC.
I don't think that was that long ago.
Right?
Yeah.
It's really recent.
That's really recent.
I think Gingiss Kahn died in the $1,200,
if I remember correctly.
100 add add.
Oh,
well did I say BC?
I actually met a day.
I said BC,
but it really did mean a dj in the more
recent 800 years.
I'm a little stone.
Folks are a lot more recent,
but that 1200,
well,
1200,
so c would still be still be pretty
fucking recent,
but 1,280,
which is what I meant to say.
Right.
So recent.
That's just not that long ago.
We're starting to make wine and sour.
Does it go the other way?
Other way?
Seven Ninety two 70 to 792 years ago a
guy killed 50 million people during his
lifetime with his actions.
Right.
They changed the carbon footprint of the
world.
I mean they,
they.
So then you're saying it's,
you're saying it's more surprising that
we're doing this kind of stuff and that
we have electric cars and medicine and
all this other kind of like it's more
surprising that we're doing that than it
is that people are running around
killing each other.
Well,
Nazi Germany,
that was 19 forties.
It's crazy.
That's maybe crazier than anything.
You know,
if you and Carla and has some great
stuff on that too,
in the history of World War One and
World War Two,
but if you're,
you're,
you're watching a documentary on that
and you watch those people move around.
Especially that one that you showed me,
Jamie,
that's been digitally remastered when
you see it in color,
is that Ken?
Is it Ken Burns it to that?
Yeah,
I think so.
They digitally remastered some footage
from World War One and you get to watch
these people move around,
like in real time you realized like,
Oh,
these are just people.
They're just just like you.
I know and this is 100 years ago,
years ago were involved in this crazy
ass war and then a few years later
involved another crazy ass war.
Yeah.
So why can't we figure it out?
Dude,
I'm telling you.
Will is present.
I don't know.
I think.
I think it used to be the only way that
people got by,
I think killing each other and I think
from going from small groups of people
which like in these small groups of
people,
they would have interpersonal conflicts.
They would have fights with members in
the tribe,
but they would sort it out and there
would probably be some sort of rule that
they would all try to live by,
but then they would get invaded by
people that didn't have anything and
we'll look for your stuff and they came
over the top of the hill and they killed
and they raped and they.
They stole women and they just did that
for a long ass time.
Man.
They did that for a long ass time.
This was the history of the steps like
that.
Dan Carlin maps out in this wrath of the
con thing makes you go,
Jesus,
Chris,
imagine being born.
Just imagine how crazy that meant.
Being a baby.
It seeing arrows flying around and
people call it open to people were
lighting people on fire and launching
them onto roofs with catapults.
This is the footage for world war one,
so
look how they digitally remastered it
and Peter Jackson movie,
I believe,
or a documentary.
That's the craziest thing.
When you look at history and you think
that,
well that was.
Then it's like,
no,
they're just us.
Just happened to be there.
Really no different than you and me,
dude,
we haven't been here this long.
We haven't been here this long.
This is the thing like people that
looked like this,
that awaring like uniforms and that are,
you know,
have like decent stuff,
nice wheels to their wagons.
That's real recent man.
No,
I know it's recent as fuck.
And there's been a bunch of different
ways that people have done it,
you know,
but even if you go back to Egypt,
so it isn't the act of like,
okay,
so we know like that guy who lit his
house on fire,
we know that is a just instinctually we
know and have known during even all this
history,
we've known that that is evil like,
right.
You know what I mean?
Like it's insanely selfish.
It's not like we went from having to
like eat each other and that we're
trying to get our act together.
You know what I mean?
There is a,
we all know that.
That is such a evil,
evil thing.
I think it exists.
I think we have to fight it.
Well,
it's,
it is evil,
but it's ego that's causing that,
right?
That guy didn't want to go to jail.
It didn't want to shoot himself,
didn't want to kill himself and didn't
want to go to jail.
So he decided he was gonna kill a bunch
of people to make up a story.
He,
he had a plot and this plot was to save
himself,
you know,
and that's when people get trapped in a
situation where they're allowed to make
decisions and they're allowed to,
if not allowed to,
but if they choose to make decisions and
those decisions are horrific and then
they have to somehow or another justify
those decisions because they never look
at their own behavior.
They always judge other people.
This is a pattern that people fall into
when they're always looking for other
people to always be wrong.
Right.
And they never grow.
And so like a guy like that,
if you so psychotic that he could kill
somebody and then he has this decision
to make this decision is to kill the
wife and the kids still like he's just
always got to be right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's always,
he's got it,
he's trying to cover his tracks,
he's trying to lie,
always like this is the type of person
that could do something like that.
Again,
this is a horrific pattern of thought
and it might have been triggered by the
murder itself,
so it's just a chemical flip in his
brain that says,
now I can kill people.
Like he hasn't done it as whole life and
he's just going into the subway and
getting a sandwich with all the stuff on
it and just be like watching the Monday
night football and then the next week
he's like,
something flips in his brain is like,
no,
now I can kill.
I don't think it's the people that I
know and love.
I think in a fit of rage,
in a fit of rage if does something
horrific.
And then I think he's one of those
people that tries to justify his
actions.
So it just tries to figure out a way
where he can justify it.
They're going to be in hell anyway
because the guy's dead.
You know,
they,
they'd probably
been thinking that deep.
He could.
You think we're crazy?
Man,
they come up with justification,
but we came from,
like we said before,
this is an Italian dude like us,
but he could've also,
we don't know if he's medicated.
Do we know that that's a brain
chemistry.
We don't know what he was doing,
you know what I mean?
He could have been on something which,
uh,
you know,
makes people do horrific things.
Do you think,
do you believe in Karma?
I think for sure that when you put
energy out there,
it affects things around you in terms of
the way people interact with you and
that in turn affects the way they will
interact with other people as well.
And I think there's,
there's,
there's a certain amount,
there's an energy you put out,
it's,
you could call it that,
but that makes it sound like you've got
a crystal in your pocket,
right?
Not really.
Energy.
Real energy is a real thing.
There's a real right.
If I was,
if I was a murderer and came and sat in
here,
there'd be a different vibe than what
you're feeling from me.
Yeah,
for sure.
You know what I mean?
For sure.
Yeah.
A chronic masturbator well,
it's also people that are off and then
struggling with the fact that they've
done something awful.
Right.
There's like an energy to that.
It's like constantly being on edge
energy.
Yeah.
Every crime and punishment.
That's still CFC.
I'd never read that.
Oh,
you should read it.
It's so he kills someone in the East
carrying the guilt.
Latest description of the Gulf.
Just carrying that thing.
Now that guy is going to admit and
energy,
but you don't think there's Karma just
for like you do something bad and
something bad will happen.
I think a genuinely believe,
and this is no crystals in my pocket,
I genuinely believe that if you do
something that you know to be awful,
that that has an equal effect coming
back at you,
like whatever bad that you've put out in
terms of like doing something evil to a
person,
the way you feel personally about
yourself,
you will take an equal blow.
I really believe that.
And where does that come from?
I think comes from your own
introspective thinking.
I think.
And worse,
you know,
you might even feel worse than that per.
You'd say something rude to a person
just because you're tired and then you
realize you said some rude,
annoying,
right.
Why did I do that?
I didn't mean.
And then they could be like Tom Papa's
not really.
Not.
I just am so tired,
you know?
And you'd just asked me something
stupid.
I'm sorry.
It's like,
it's hard to turn that around.
Yeah.
So you might hate yourself more than
they even get mad at you.
So Karma is really,
you're dealing with the energy.
It's not the universe saying now
something bad's going to happen to you.
You're kind of creating it with your own
actions and your own stuff.
I think it's real dangerous when we
pretend that we have any sort of real
understanding of the patterns,
all the events that take place in the
world.
So when you start to say like someone,
something happened to someone because of
Karma.
That's okay.
The problem with saying that is what
about babies?
What about babies with leukemia?
Were they bad babies?
What happened?
Why did they get cancer?
Why they die young?
Why did they die in car accidents?
Why?
That doesn't make any sense.
They've never done anything bad there,
but that's where you could say that bad
shit happens to us all,
but can you create more bad shit
possible co two and it's also entirely
possible that you're creating more bad
shit but feeling bad about yourself
because you've done bad shit so you
create more of this negative energy that
you carry around with you.
I think that's entirely possible too.
But I think that we also have this weird
need to define things,
you know,
and I think that we're looking to this
thing that we're calling Karma and we're
saying that this is like,
this is definite correlation between
action and reaction and between the good
you put out there and the good that
comes back and my take is that I think
there's definitely something going on,
but I don't think we should define it
yet because I don't think we really
know.
And I think as soon as we box it up and
say it's this thing and this is the
absolute reaction that the world has.
When you put good out there,
good comes back.
Good people die all the time,
folks.
Good people die.
I think there's.
I think there is an energy.
Yeah,
and you know,
we know it from the work that we do.
I think it's both.
When you stand on stage,
there's an energy in that room that
transference between you and the people
that are out there and you're playing
with it and it's a real thing.
It's a very real thing.
It's like hypnosis,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It is.
And and then they can.
They can reverse hip,
hypnotize you.
They could bring this other energy the
other way so that there is this energy
of all of us out there and running
around.
It's not that far to think then there
couldn't be good energy and there's bad
energy and there's an.
Is that ultimately good and evil?
Maybe it is all generated from human
beings.
Maybe if you educated everyone and they
could all be kind and try and come at it
that way we could actually feel that
there was more good,
but that's just more good coming from
people I don't know.
Well,
if you want to get really spacey with
this really,
really spacey,
it's the holidays you go,
okay,
well what?
What exactly are people doing?
That's what you do here.
What are people doing?
What are they doing?
Like,
what's our purpose to be being here?
Look at us from an outside perspective,
like pretend you're not a person.
You're looking at all the people like
what are they doing?
They're moving really fast.
They're spending most of their time
doing things they don't want to do and
they're buying stuff bustling around
because they're throwing all this money
at stuff.
The stuff keeps getting better,
so every year the stuff keeps getting
more complex and more capable and more
high tech and more space age.
This is bananas,
man.
I to watch her and call me fucking Dick
Tracy man,
right?
Yeah,
and that as people keep going on and on
and on and on with this stuff.
This is where we need some sort of
energy behind this innovation and a lot
of the energy is conflict.
Conflict and resolution.
Conflict and victory,
victory and defeat and the defeat makes
your work harder and and there's all
these interacting forces that are
constantly moving together.
I'm with you,
ended this.
A lot of it is expressed.
The success of this little game has
expressed in material possessions.
The success in this game is expressed in
Hamptons mansions and private jets and
bentleys and Pam.
I'm winning this fucking crazy game.
OPS and there's a lot of value and
winning the crazy game who stopped so we
let these people acquire all this stuff
and you've got all these diamonds and
fuck yeah,
this is.
This is forcing more stuff to be made
better and more innovation,
which will eventually,
and this is where it gets spacious of
all waiting for this part.
This is going to be what people become.
People are going to become some sort of
symbiotic organism.
Something that's tied into electronics
and that it's happening now.
It's happening slowly and we're making
it with stuff and as we keep making
stuff,
it's eventually going to get to a part
that was the thing you would like to do
more than anything is have enhanced your
experience on earth.
Right.
I want to be able to take pictures.
Yes.
I want to be able to email people.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
but I also want to.
I want it to make my experience on earth
better.
Well then we're going to have to
integrate with your circuitry,
Tom,
papa,
and then live forever.
Maybe.
Maybe that's what the organisms are
trying to do.
We're trying to get rid of the monkey
that wants to start the wars all the
time.
Right.
It's enlightenment that towards the end
of our goofy ass system,
evil living there would be a great
science fiction movie,
but if this is the future and they
probably were already made it,
but if only some people went on board
with a new enlightenment that you get
from these headsets.
Like remember the dude from Star Trek,
the blind guy from sesame street.
Remember he was used to be on sesame
street,
right?
Yeah,
that he was the uh,
Lavar Burton Rainbow Boulevard.
Yeah.
Reading Rainbow,
Lavar,
Burton,
Barbara,
yeah.
Yeah.
We all have those things on it.
There's only like 10 of them for what if
no one bought into most people bought
into it and those things completely cure
you of any evil.
It just moving along.
I think that uh,
I don't know.
I mean there was,
maybe there is no purpose to us being
here,
but you got that shit for pep boys.
That's a filter.
That's a really good,
cool air filter at the top of the
muscle,
isn't it?
Come on.
That's a 69 chevy.
Yeah.
You bought,
you bought that at the auto parts store
and put it in your dose.
Yoda Corola dope old ones,
man.
When they fucking unscrew the chrome
hubcap filter down.
I always liked a good wing man and
people don't remember man.
These people today,
you don't remember what gas smells like.
Oh Man.
You could fix your own car.
You could open it up and with a
screwdriver and a high school education,
fix your automobile.
I was never smart enough or
knowledgeable enough to fix my own car,
but I could do little things.
I can change my oil.
Changed to a lot of things with old.
Exactly.
Did the brakes once I did the brakes,
hit the brakes.
That's a bold move.
What if you're wrong?
I was poor.
I didn't have money.
I've just been buying brake pads.
Was a lot cheaper than having some
guidance.
Did you put it up on a Jack?
How'd you put it up on a jack and a
cinderblock that held it underneath and
yeah,
it was nice.
It was a light little car.
Little pads.
Put them in.
I probably had to get it fixed after
that,
but.
But yeah,
you could fix stuff.
There was like a time when you could
actually.
And you felt good about it,
but.
But yeah,
if you had to choose between one of
those fucking rickety ship boxes,
that's like a rhinoceros on roller
skates versus your Tesla.
Yeah.
No,
there's no way things can go.
Fuck.
No,
and I wouldn't put.
I wouldn't put my kids in one of those
that we're driving around in those death
traps.
Do like no steering.
No airbags.
Hydroplane at the drop of a hat.
Exactly.
Just spinning around.
So engine heavy.
Remember it was a big ass engine's in
the front.
They didn't know what I'm asking.
Would just slide all over the place.
It was so easy to slide your car back
then.
It was totally beat with your friends.
Just like spinning out and they figured
out how to balance them.
That's like,
that's the big deal.
Like if you take a tesla or anything,
you buy a fucking camry.
Okay.
That camera handles better than a 69
Camaro.
Fuck it.
I wouldn't like to see what the death
rates are better a on the roads now with
like new cars.
It's got to be.
It's probably much better.
I mean they're.
They're much safer,
but they're also much faster too.
Yeah,
but you don't have to drive very fast
for it to be fatal.
I didn't know how to make stuff.
Everything was glass just filled with
gasoline.
That and fucking sparks and fumes.
Fumes were everywhere.
Driving be getting high from the fumes,
right?
I remember when I was working,
uh,
for a fireplace company in the summer in
New Jersey and it was in a truck and
we're in this truck and traffic of the
New Jersey turnpike right by Newark
airport and just the fumes from
everything from the city,
from a car.
And it was just arinze in the humidity
of New Jersey.
I was like,
if I get cancer,
this is gonna be the day that it,
that it hit me.
And it makes people crazy.
It's like,
it's like
throwing alcohol and fire.
So freedom that dust all day.
So disgusting.
Pull up a video of the sound of the
exhaust of a 1969 Camaro.
There is something to somethings the
smell of gas is a good smell slot.
Just that man,
if that sound,
there's a sound.
Oh,
how about this one?
Even better.
Nineteen Sixty Chevelle,
1970 Chevelle.
Ss
America doesn't evil about that sound.
That is a drive.
One of those mother fuckers around was
very cool.
I mean,
the bumper cars is preposterous as they
are
present a lot of ways.
What's great about America?
Yeah,
the excess.
Exactly.
Not giving a shit.
It's just so outrageous.
Let's go.
Let's have a good time.
Fucking giant metal explosion contained
in the front of the hood.
That's all it is.
A giant ass
explosion box.
Look at this.
Who?
That's the 69.
Sixty nine.
Oh my God.
This guy gloriousness.
You see heaven on earth,
right?
Oh,
19.
Sixty nine Chevelle.
Look how pretty that car is,
man.
If this guy is across the street from me
and I'm looking at with my coffee out of
my window and he comes pulling out with
that because Saturday morning,
you know what I'm saying?
What?
This guy's an asshole.
Do you hear her be with his new car?
Do you know what?
There are midlife.
You say that
you say that,
but I guarantee you if you were next
door and he just walked over and looked
at it,
it would catch you in its bell would
cross the street.
It's just rack it.
Jesus Christ.
Why is your car after be so loud?
Yeah,
but if you're right next to it,
you're like,
wow,
1969 and you'll start walking around.
It's pretty bad,
so it's beautiful.
It's not.
You can't make a car like that today
because it's not even remotely
aerodynamic.
Hammock.
Fuel efficient.
It's not safe.
There's a pitiful man.
They nailed it.
They hit the sweet spot in art and
engineering.
That is the one part of the American
experience.
Recklessness.
That's what drives everything that there
is that element of balls to the wall.
Let's see what happens.
Let's discover and you could get good
things out of it.
Right?
But imagine this,
imagine something that's far inferior to
the modern alternative but makes you
feel in a way the modern alternative
isn't capable.
Feeling
like if you see in 1969,
like done up Mustang Gt.
What?
What was the like the big one that year
one.
Was it a mock one?
What the fuck was the 1970?
Was it a boss?
That's what it was.
[inaudible].
Sixty nine was like a boss and then
earlier than that they made those
eleanor cars for that gone in 60
seconds.
I think those were 19,
67,
so really not there.
That body style,
like if you looked at one of those next
to a 2018 mustang,
the 2018 mustangs look fucking great.
They look great.
That's it right there.
That's a mock one.
Yeah,
that's it.
Oh,
that's right.
It's John Rice dude.
There's a company that's making these
now too.
They're called classic recreation's and
they're making these brand new versions
of that car they take.
They take 19,
69 mustangs and they rebuild them,
but they give him like real break,
so they stopped good modern suspension.
They make it so you can drive it around.
That's what I'm interested in.
That.
That makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense because
they're just pretty mustang bad ass
tires,
but that's when you at
that.
How beautiful is that?
It doesn't look like anything that you
can buy that's modern.
Like there's nothing remotely close.
No.
That's like vinyl.
They just right there.
They just nailed it.
Whatever the fuck they did
all these years later,
we're like,
God damn it.
They nailed it.
Right.
But they nailed it for,
you know,
certain,
a lunkhead from New Jersey that doesn't
do that for you.
Yeah,
it does.
But I don't know.
I don't know if you don't know if young
people would like that.
I don't know.
They're like to start arresting them.
If they don't like young boys don't look
down Mustang and say good God credible.
If they don't do that then they should
probably go to jail somewhere that is
pretty hot.
That's incredibly good looking.
But it's stupid.
But it's also stupid.
Wow.
So sir,
it's just metal right in your chest
cavity.
No,
no airbag.
You need to do more push of last just in
your face.
It's probably a little bit of that.
No,
I know a chunk in a car accident and
drive carefully and it's a wonderful
thing to behold.
Yeah.
My buddy had his bad mustang when we
were in high school,
but if you saw something like that but
it had airbags,
he'd be cool with it then.
Yeah.
No,
I'm cool with it.
Anyway,
I'm just busting Paul's,
but I think it's a look at that little
orange thing in the middle that looks
closer to what?
I had.
A 76 Toyota Corolla.
Call that up.
Call up in 1976 Toyota Corolla with a
with a a racing stripes along the side.
Look at that bad boy.
Look at that orange one in the second
row.
That was it.
I had a 1984 Honda accord.
80 four Honda accord with stuttering
spark.
That's the 79.
You need the 76.
Those are cool little cars though.
That's.
I could fix that car at those.
That's what I was doing the brakes on.
Yeah,
it looks like one of those.
Something like that.
It was white.
Nice little shitty carbon legend.
Oh,
it's just like this.
Oh know what man?
Here's the thing.
Those fucking cars drive forever.
Yeah,
exactly.
they are.
It's amazing how reliable Honda's are.
Oh yeah,
they're so insane.
Toyota Toyota's.
Oh my God.
Just go forever.
Just having that crummy car.
It was a good thing.
But.
So you think back to your,
uh,
your point of view of the,
what are these people doing here?
So they're building.
I liked where you were going,
making stuff for what,
what'd,
because everything's electronically
based and is this all instinct is or is
it being steered by something?
We just finding our way in the dark and
this is what's coming out or is there
some plan?
Well,
that's a heavy question.
It's really hard to know if there was a
plan.
Yeah,
I get,
I get why some would be suspicious that
there would be,
but if you just see the whole nature
right,
with the starting off of the tribal
behavior and the invasions of the others
and the wars that have taken place sort
of nonstop,
right?
Yeah.
You get this hyper competitive team
oriented thing broken into countries.
Well,
I think that with that and this like
constant competition in this constant
and then inside your country,
this constant competition economically
and everybody just striving to achieve
and do better and get crazier and
bigger.
And this is all leading to us just
continuing to buy stuff like everybody
that is involved in this as buying the
newest iphone or the newest macbook,
the newest,
this news.xbox.
Fucking.
How many x boxes have been now for?
Let's just say four.
Four.
Yeah.
Going to keep going,
keep going.
They're going to go xbox five.
They're going to.
They're going to keep going.
It's what everybody does.
They want better shit.
You Want Vr?
We want.
I will not hyper realistic Vr.
I want vr with no gear.
I want you to be able to give me a pill
and that pill releases a bunch of
nanobots that go through my circulatory
system and find my,
my brain and juice it up.
But some artificial memory.
I mean that's what I want.
And I share them out later.
Like buck shots and right clink.
Yeah,
kidney stones.
You Shit it out.
Like buckshot like little babies coming
out in your poop.
This is mean.
Look,
beings always try to find safety,
right?
That's what they want more than
anything.
They don't want to get killed.
They want to.
They want to be safe and exist,
eat whatever,
but they just want to be.
They want that safety,
so maybe our safety is going to come
when we're out of the woods were out of
the wild where out of the 20th century
and we're just these insular things that
never have to go out and about and
forever and
just be [inaudible] could be.
Maybe that's what all this push of
technology is,
is aiming towards.
Yeah.
It could be right.
Just to protect ourselves in these
little cocoons and and be.
Yeah.
I mean if the ultimate threats always
violence and war,
right.
That's the ultimate threat to the
organism and the organism can commit
violence and war against each other,
which is why we make doors and gates and
stuff to keep those things at bay.
Yup.
Yeah,
but it's the most fascinating things
that people don't address.
Like what would,
what would cause a person to snap?
There's no real concrete,
no concrete answer.
What do you think is the difference
between,
and I'm asking this honestly killing
when you're hunting and killing a human
being.
I think it would be a giant difference
terms of where you fell.
Yeah.
How could you articulate it though?
I don't know.
I've never killed a human being,
but I would,
I would imagine that it would be,
um,
I mean it would have to be some horrific
situation where you're battling for your
life,
which people do that.
It does happen,
you know,
we were all aware of it.
The worst possible scenario we would all
like to think that everybody that we
meet that's of sound mind should be our
brothers and sisters.
I mean we should all get along whether
you agree or disagree about certain
political issues or certain social
issues,
like we should be able to talk through
that as a community.
But like always hold at the top that
we're all in this together and if I
think that's possible,
I think that's possible and I think we
could still satisfy this fucked up
desire that we have to constantly
compete.
We can temper that with what I think is
the most important thing is finding
something that you're passionate at
because I think you and I are really,
really lucky that we found stand up and
through stand up.
We found this thing that we're
passionate at and we have a good time
and we have fun.
Some people don't have that,
so like if I.
If you were offered a job as a
stockbroker and this is a guaranteed
job,
you have a guaranteed contract for the
next 20 years,
you're going to make five times as much
as you make doing stand up.
You can't do standup anymore.
He would never take that.
You'd be like,
wow.
So even though you're a guy who does
well,
you're not a business person.
You're a guy following your passion and
it's allowed you to live a nice life,
but that doesn't.
It's not the same as a lot of people
with a lot of people are doing is just
chasing the money so the,
the passion doesn't exist and they can
manufacture that passion.
When it comes to like some desire to see
their,
their team kick ass because their
companies,
number one,
it could be,
could be really that they are into
succeeding in the business world and
that's their passion.
They liked a lot of people that like
that,
but it's not the same as a guy like
David Cho who's like a professional
artist who's making.
He's.
He just follows his passion.
He does what he wants.
There's a different kind of achievement.
There's a feeling that he has the way he
interfaces with what he does for a
living that's different than what a lot
of people do.
So I would imagine that artists would
probably be less inclined to go crazy
and spend all their money on stuff and
buy things that make them look better or
make them feel better about the fact
that they work because they're not
trying to fill a hole that.
Right.
But if you're just,
you have a job for a company that you
don't really give a fuck about.
You don't really give a fuck about
styrofoam coolers.
You know,
you really don't give a fuck about
fucking,
you know,
those rubber bands that people buy when
they have causes.
You don't give a fuck about this
company,
right?
You're just a fucking guy who does it.
Your Business and you're there at,
okay,
well,
you know,
we can give them to you for 1796 if we
can work this through Bob.
We're talking about a thousand bucks.
Want to be there?
Like,
I want to be fishing.
The guy wants to be doing something
else.
Yeah,
you don't.
You,
you're insanely fortunate that you don't
have that in your life.
No,
but I think,
I don't think those people look.
A lot of people have jobs that they're
not into,
but the reason we're lucky is that our
job is our passion.
A lot of people have the job that
they're maybe not into,
but they love this other stuff that they
do.
They love being with their family and
keep teaching soccer or they love skiing
or whatever.
Their passion is something else.
It like.
We're lucky that our passion is our work
to combine those things.
That is a very,
very unique thing.
It's the most insanely lucky thing ever,
but I think that for people that are
like hyper competitive,
that don't find a thing that they really
love,
then it really,
for many of them becomes about pursuing
the best stuff.
Yeah,
and you.
This is what fuels so many people for
like these status symbols or like if you
have an iphone eight,
if a kid sees you with an iphone eight
and they got an iphone 10 period,
you weird.
They can basically do the exact same
thing.
Has a fucking killer camera.
Iphone eight,
you know,
with the battery's pretty similar to our
tiny amy,
but for status seeking people,
it's very important that you have the
latest stuff.
Like you can't be walking around with,
like David tells the other day with an
iphone to burst out laughing
immediately.
He got on.
Twitter is hilarious.
You know,
there's nothing about a tell.
It is a searching for status.
None.
No.
He's like,
I was saying that.
He's like a monk you that way.
He is.
Yeah,
you're right.
He's smart.
He's very smart,
brilliant guy.
He knows.
He knows what's healthy for them and
what's not.
So other than the cigarettes.
Yeah.
He put all his other stuff.
He stopped drinking and didn't know.
He cleaned himself up really well and
the cigarettes and the only vice.
He has cigarettes and coffee.
He was saying that's his vice.
He's a.
he's a poet amongst us.
Like he's.
He's somebody that he's special.
He really.
And he's a really good
guy.
Yeah.
Now he's so kind.
He's so kind of just being around his
orbit.
I love New York.
I love the two of them together.
Yeah.
No,
it's really.
It's so funny.
I never would have seen that coming when
I was,
when we were all young in New York.
I know,
right.
I never would have saw those two.
Yeah,
right.
Doing it.
I don't know what.
Not for any real reason,
but it just never saw them intersecting.
I never would've saw any of us doing
something like that.
Yeah.
You doing live shows together.
Great idea.
It is a great idea.
Like some of those shows.
You see those pictures for the comedy
cellar?
Yeah,
like 1:00
in the morning.
Like Dave Chappelle's onstage with Chris
Rock and fucking around,
you know,
there's always like three guys on stage.
That's crazy.
I know.
Never,
I never understand that either.
But being around it's hell.
Like watching him all through the years.
He would always surprise you like when
someone's father died or something,
have a towel.
Was always front and center,
like helping out,
giving people money.
Like there's this kindness to them
gentlemen.
Con Guy.
Yeah.
And another force of good real force of
good.
And a guy who uh,
like comics should really appreciate,
like if you're a fan of the art form,
like David tells really someone to
appreciate it because was always
creative.
It's,
it's like it's never do she always
skanks for the memories as one of my all
time favorite.
That shit is hilarious.
That is so funny.
Is a hilarious cd man.
I think he did that in Denver,
you know?
Yeah.
He did that at the comedy works.
Oh yeah.
Wendy's put.
Oh,
very cool.
Yeah,
that's very cool.
Yeah.
That fucking in Denver,
that CDs brilliant.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
He's so good.
Yeah.
I mean to answer what you're saying.
Yeah,
your face here and it's so silly.
I think that was when he was doing
insomnia too,
right?
Yeah.
That was the partying days.
He says he's just such a smart guy.
Like he just decided one point,
hey,
this is fucking me up.
No more drinking to no more drinking,
no more show.
You're not going to do this thing.
That's attracting negativity to my shows
and setting me up as a guy.
It's going.
Drank himself into oblivion.
Know he was smart.
He pulled the uh,
pull the cord.
Yeah,
those,
those.
You're,
you're the party guy.
You're the life of the party guy.
It's hard to sit back down.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
What's Zen game?
Or it talked to Ron White.
He's,
he's doing it with us and Ron White on
white.
Stop faking.
I'll tell you exactly what Ron White's
doing.
He's riding a fucking boat.
Riding into the rock is.
He doesn't give a fuck and he's doing it
with a Tequila company.
Cheers.
Happy holidays.
My friend,
I set up my train under my tree.
Knew what does it numero won is that is
a Tequila company.
I just said I set my train up under my
tree and you still chose onto Keelan.
Did you have photos or videos of this
train on your tree?
I think I didn't put anything on the
instagram.
Probably wouldn't be real if it wasn't.
It's hard stuff in your life.
My kids are getting older.
There's like 16 and 13 and they were at
school and I'm setting up the village
under the tree and the train tracks and
all the people like shopping around the
village and that was doing it on my own
because they don't have time to really
do it and I was like,
this is how people become the guy in the
neighborhood is like bringing your
children around.
Look at my train set because your family
leaves and you're like,
are there any children around?
They want to look at my train set.
I could totally see myself doing that at
some point.
Totally.
Well there's those dudes that they go
wall close encounters of the third kind
make that giant one in the middle of the
living room.
You're funny reference.
Yeah,
because they had the plywood number,
horse,
like the extra in the middle of his
house.
His wife divorced him.
Yeah.
That guy.
You make a train around that.
It's not that far from that.
I can't remember his name.
Richard Dreyfus course.
Jesus Christ.
Richard Dreyfus.
A great movie.
Well,
Daca,
he's been great in so many things.
Always.
The unassuming guy.
Jaws.
Yeah,
man,
he was.
He was Spielberg's alter ego.
Really be so good.
Yeah.
He's so good in everything.
He looks so young.
There was man,
man.
Oh Man.
What a fucking movie this was because I
wanted to believe so bad.
Oh yeah.
I so wanted to believe they got me.
Hey,
did you talk about that Berg?
Did you talk about that alien craft that
came into her?
What happened to our galaxy?
It did very well with the Hawaiian name.
Oh,
so it's over.
You didn't hear about that one.
The one that looks like a joint.
Yeah,
because we're a big piece of poop that a
big duty copter.
It's just a weird rock.
I think now they said that,
uh,
some like legit people said that it
changed speed and went in different
directions.
People,
legit people.
Scientists.
Oh,
them guys said that it was a,
it could be something.
Could be.
What does Neil Degrassi say about it?
He's not talking right now.
I'm a little bit of a kerfuffle.
Kerfuffle.
What's his gym?
Harvard scientists say aliens.
Makes Bizarre.
Interstellar object.
Yeah.
I saw that.
And then I saw someone refuting
scientists.
Harvard.
No one wants to believe more than me,
bro.
Come on Joe.
It's real.
Well,
if I was going to mask my spaceship to
fly through the galaxy,
I would definitely make it look like a
big rock.
Big Asteroid.
Right?
Why wouldn't you driving through space?
May.
Maybe what they were like,
look,
if we just make this thing
drive by them and don't change speeds,
they'll have no idea.
Just destroyed.
There'll be psyched that we missed them.
Okay.
Good call.
Someone just hits the gas.
I'm tired.
I don't want to fucking taking too long.
You got the fucking cops are behind.
Is Dave Shit.
Goddammit.
Dave.
You're not supposed to.
Just take all told you 65.
Fuck,
let's start throwing this weed out the
window.
Why would it be so hard to believe a
space rock traveling through space?
That would be the move,
right?
I mean,
if they're so advanced they can travel
through galaxies.
They can make this shit look like
anything they want it to.
Why wouldn't you doll it up?
Radiation pressure.
The only thing celebrating floors would
be.
Well,
there's no air and space,
right?
So it wouldn't be aerodynamics.
What would it be?
Momentum.
No,
go down a little bit.
I think it answers your question.
If radiation pressure is the
accelerating forest,
then own moma represents a new class of
thin interstellar material.
Whoa.
It has a different thing that it's using
for energy.
But as to what may have produced this
previously unseen material,
it could have emerged naturally from the
debris of the planet forming disc in a
distant solar system going through yet
an unknown process.
They've got a whole nother way to make.
We went from Toyota Corollas to this
thing.
Imagine if that's what we find.
The only thing though,
that's what it does.
The,
um,
the,
like a rock a rock is not smooth,
but it doesn't necessarily need this
where I'm stupid.
This is one of many places where I'm
stupid,
but it doesn't necessarily need to be
aerodynamic.
Right,
because it's not going through air.
The vacuum of space.
Right?
Exactly.
So I'm not wrong there.
It could actually look like a rock.
It comes.
The only issue would be getting it into
space.
Right?
The aerodynamics.
Assuming that you shooting it from a
planet with an atmosphere.
Again,
gravity not be talking about this way
too stupid.
If you shot,
if you're launching it from Earth into
space,
right?
Yeah.
What if you had it encased in like this
outer area?
Sort of like the space shuttle is,
but then once you get to a place you
could jettison the outside of it just
like they get rid of those booster
rockets,
they just fall into the bucket,
integrate land on people,
whether fishing.
That has to happen.
Right.
Getting killed by a booster rocket flat
space that you in the face.
I didn't integrate,
but then they could do that.
They could release the shell and then
they would just have the rock and the
rock would move through space and it
didn't matter what shape it was because
it's in the vacuum
or just get it up into orbit,
orbit the space station.
Go and build it in pieces and then
launch it for sure.
Do you remember when that commander,
Chris Hadfield gentleman was on the
podcast and he was talking about some
kind of magnet that they have that
collects subatomic
out there in the galaxy and that we only
know five percent of what the universe
is made out of.
Oh my God.
Talking about things like dark matter
and he was five percent.
It's the guys scientists space,
a real legit astronaut coming back from
six months in space or whatever the fuck
he was there for and telling us this.
Really,
wow what we've talked about that like
you can hang with those guys for a
little while and then you're like,
I don't understand what's happening now.
It's also the.
I mean,
it's amazing what we do know,
amazing that they can send a guy to
space and have them fly around the ISS
or.
Yeah,
I mean we'll talk about what you were
saying about why are we here and what
are we doing like we haven't developed
yet.
Something that you can go the speed of
light we haven't,
but if we do then the whole universe is
open to us.
Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe the struggle of developing all
this stuff is to get to a scientific
level where we can really go.
I don't think they think the speed of
light is even good enough.
Really?
Yeah.
I think,
dammit,
that was my goal.
I think that like if you wanted to have
options available as to what planet
you're gonna colonize,
you gotta have to.
Who knows what?
If you land on a planet,
what did he land on a planet and it's
like,
Hey,
it's 74 degrees out guys.
Guys,
it's all oxygen and nitrogen.
It's just like earth.
Come on out here.
But it's only been like that for 10
years and then cycle is really fucked up
like 30 years from now.
It's going to be a nice age.
It will be for all the people have moved
there and they're going to freeze to
death is going to be no food at all.
Planet doesn't give a fuck.
Like that's all our science led us to
that I don't even know if we can
predict.
Here's my question.
Can they accurately predict the
atmosphere and the conditions and what
the temperature would be if a planet is
from a son,
like did they have a calculation where
they say,
oh this sun is this amount of big and
this planet is this far away.
So it's definitely going to stay within
a certain temperature range for the
entire time that the planet.
Did they know that like within like a
death range?
I think they must.
Death range is 40 degrees bro.
Yeah.
You get to 140.
That's a wrap.
Yeah.
You're done.
So like $100.
One hundred 40.
Everyone's dead,
right?
You live in a sauna,
you're going to run out of water.
I just don't think we're going to make
it.
We're not,
we're definitely not figuring it out
because we're saying this amount of big,
we're not even helping.
We're confusing the pro,
but seriously think about that just as a
concept.
Like maybe that is it.
Maybe it's baby all this like you keep
thinking,
you know,
you talked a lot about all the robots
and the things that are moving us
forward,
but why?
But why?
And I had the cocoon theory before,
but maybe that's not it.
Maybe it's so we can really go.
Yeah.
I've had the cocoon theory for quite a
while where I think that we are like
some sort of an electronic caterpillar
that's building some cocoon
and then a butterfly is going to emerge
because when,
when as a collective like will all be
part of this.
I mean just the innovation and the
computers and the Ai and our integration
with them that eventually it's just
going to get smarter and crazier and
weirder.
I mean it's only a matter of time before
they make something that resembles a
person.
It sounds to a insular.
No,
it sounds too insular that it would just
be for us to stay here on earth.
The universe is so vast that there may.
I think it's more likely that we're
going to go out of this.
That's a very good idea.
This is the sense.
It's kind of a sewer.
Oh,
but is it though?
It's amazing.
Well,
it's beautiful.
There's parts that.
Come on,
man.
We have a lovely life.
You ever been to Utah to skip or you
look at the stars or look at the
beautiful,
beautiful clouds in the sky on a day
like today.
Oh my lovely.
You go outside.
This clouds float around,
just gives you a just right amount of
sun.
A little bit of contrast is the best.
Lovely.
Like why would,
how could you say this is a sewer?
Because so many parts that are
disgusting.
There's so many parts,
not,
not so many parts because we still have
this evil,
this other stuff that's clog at each
other and knocking each other and it's
still filled with.
Right,
but a murder.
Not right here.
It's only in certain spots.
So this is the other thing that we tend
to do because we have 7 billion people
on the planet and cameras on all of
them.
Yeah.
And everybody's got a camera and we're
exchanging these stories.
You're catching stories from an an
unimaginable number of humans.
Right?
And so even if we're looking at just our
country,
there's so many people just to La.
So many people.
It's $20,
million people.
It's insane.
What's really amazing that's really
amazing is not just how far human beings
have come over the last hundred,
200,
300 years.
But what's really amazing is if you just
look at the actual numbers of times that
people interact with each other,
how few of them are violent.
Yeah.
Especially in a place like America in
2018.
I think about that on the freeway.
All so many people because it just.
You're right.
And they're all pretty much acting in an
orderly fashion to preserve themselves
and others.
Yeah.
You ever,
every now and then you have someone
that's just crazy,
just violates all the rules.
Just weaving in traffic drive at 150
miles an hour in a residential
community.
Maybe it's just a mutation.
Maybe that's just a mutation,
you know,
I think it is.
I think it is in the same way those
things exists in like a biological
system,
right?
You can get these little diseases,
a little bugs.
It's little things that are off,
you know,
and then you have an immune system.
The battles,
the bugs.
Yeah.
Like when you see stuff about
chimpanzees are and there's like
everyone's getting along trying to do
their thing,
their struggles,
but then there's a real mutation.
Like there's someone that,
there's one that kills the rest of them
and won't be part of the thing,
you know,
that's what we have.
We have these kind of like renegade
mutations run by evil swipe.
We should all go back to what's
interesting is done in large groups,
right?
And all of us together,
like the way we interact with each other
is generally nonviolent.
Whoever these large groups will decide
by whatever,
you know,
whoever's in charge to attack other
large groups.
And this is where the big death comes
from,
right?
This is where the real toll comes from
in war.
Right?
So,
but if you looked at the actual
communities of people from one side or
the other,
like the groups themselves together,
how much are they really in conflict
with those other people?
Probably not nearly as much as the
people that are in charge would want
them to be,
which.
Right.
Which is that.
It's almost like the mutation is in
charge because you take two groups that
are at war and you put them together.
They're just hanging out drinking beer
together.
We're all the same age.
There was probably have a great time
together.
They're leaders.
Talk them into leaders or the mutation.
That's when things get scary.
Whether it's the Hitler leader or you
know,
North Korea do whatever the Russians do,
dating places.
They're talking people into invading
places.
That's some slip.
Every justification.
Yeah.
No,
that's where the world gets very
strange.
And I think it's interesting that those
people in those groups,
you know,
all come from all over the world or all
over the country list all these
different place in,
they're brought together.
Right?
But look how we've progressed.
There's fewer of those kinds of
conflicts now than ever before.
Right.
But you and I,
and I think a lot of other people would
like it to be zero amount,
right?
Yeah.
But Donald,
I don't know if that's ever gonna
happen,
man.
That's a weird thing to say because you
would,
would like everybody to be in a good
place in this world,
but you'll,
I almost wonder if like many things,
it's just like this push of good things
happening in band things positive and
negative,
and that this battle between the two of
them is what creates all this momentum
and all this movement.
That's the good and evil.
We're back to the good and evil.
So maybe we should go back to church.
Look,
the priests did some weird stuff,
but maybe we.
It's good people in there more than evil
people.
Well,
the problem is with that church in
particular,
they're still shielding the people that
have done terrible things.
Yeah.
There's just no denying that there's.
If you look at the facts,
if you look at everything that's come
out,
there's no denying that.
That's super unfortunate because I think
the vast majority of the people that are
involved in the religion that aren't the
people that are pedophiles,
I think they're very good people that
probably think about it the same way.
Maybe your daughter would like to think
about it,
that some place where people can get
together and they exchange affection and
comradery and uh,
and this acceptance of something higher
than them that holds them to a certain
standard and wants to be good people.
And that's for everybody.
Good for everybody.
But if it wasn't for all that kid
fucking oh,
that kid fucking just ruined all that.
It just.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's such a sad,
sad thing.
Google this,
because I've said this many times and
I've never bothered looking at it up
there.
The reason why we can get another bottle
that if you want to get fucked up the
holidays.
Okay,
so holidays,
um,
shit,
lot of sediment in that.
What were we just talking about?
Good and evil and the priests and the
why they're ruining your own use to go
get that video.
Look.
Something up.
You haven't looked before.
Reason why.
Oh,
that's it.
Thank you.
Thought that was gone forever.
I voted the reason why they forced
priest to be celibate because what I had
heard.
Oh,
was it?
This is not no scholarly work of my own.
I don't remember even reading the
article.
I think somebody told it to me that
priests were banging too many chips.
Bravo.
He might've said it in that way.
Too many chicks,
man.
They made a mess out of it.
Which I think.
I don't think that was it.
What do you think it is?
I think it was property.
I think that when priests,
priests owned property and if they were
married and he died,
she would keep the property.
If there was no woman involved and he
owned the property and he couldn't be
with a woman and he swore that he was
just with Jesus when he died,
the property went to the church.
Yeah.
That's,
you know,
which is not much of.
I mean,
that's crazy.
It's wow.
That whole other part of Catholicism is
the other thing that bumps me all the
time.
When you go to the Vatican,
it's like,
wow,
this is beautiful,
but what were they?
Get all this art.
Where'd they get all these bills?
The pillaging of fuck of religions where
the shit stolen from a time where people
are starving in the streets.
I know this is how powerful religion is.
This is how powerful this pull is to
search for good and to be a part of
something is in light of those things
that you see the wealth.
It's like going into like a pirate ship
and seeing all the shit that they got
and then knowing what they do with these
children,
both those things are.
You should just say,
fuck this.
I'm not going to be.
I'm not going to be a part of this at
all,
but the,
the,
the other part of it is so strong that
you actually will kind of say,
well,
yeah,
but I'm still going to go to mass on
Sunday.
I think,
you know,
what that means is you think that even
if a priest is bad,
that the religion is still good.
You know,
the,
the idea is that this is like a bad guy
who lost his way.
That's sort of human beings that are
flawed.
Got a lot of them are drunk two men who
read my grandma's.
Oh,
my grandma's eulogy.
No,
her name was Josephine.
He kept calling her Geraldine.
No,
they had to correct them.
It's Josephine,
like he was.
He was saying all these great things
about her.
He didn't know who he was and he had
those Jim Blossoms.
Oh,
Jamie brought it into the bottle of
wine.
Oh,
Mike savage,
savage,
Jamie,
Jamie.
But,
uh,
the,
I think,
you know,
you take a guy and you put them in that
position where he can't have a
companion.
Like you're not allowed to have a love.
He can't have a wife or a husband or
whatever.
You can't have that.
You're not allowable thing fighting
nature.
There was a kid that I went to high
school with that,
uh,
became a priest.
We all knew.
We all knew like it was.
It was like a thing you knew like,
oh,
this is why it's going to be a priest.
We get it.
Right.
Well,
that's what a lot of people say.
It's like that the church,
the other side of the church doesn't
create pedophiles that like the
institution attracts them because they
know they'll be safe there.
Well,
it's possible,
but it's also possible that so many of
them that are active in the church,
and I don't know what this guy's story
was,
I barely knew him,
but that he could have been molested.
I mean is not.
It's not a small number of kids that
were molested to very large,
large,
and you would never mean who the fuck
understands what that would be like to
be a young boy to have that happen to
you and then get groomed and
indoctrinated into being a part of this
thing that does that other young boys in
the future.
So your whole reality,
which has to be with some of them are,
and they're all doing this under the
blanket of this thing called the church.
Then when the church finds out about it,
the church moves people to all these
different various places and they,
they get these new victims and this
happens over and over and over again.
You know,
this was one of the things that they
were saying about benedict about.
I'm the one who before.
Cool.
Yeah.
He had actively done that.
He adapted.
He was stolen people.
Yeah.
It was a part of that.
So bad,
so bad,
and it's such a shame.
It was married Catholic priests there.
Perhaps 120 in the US already.
Here's how well it was this a new thing.
The other article I found that there's
about 200.
Wow.
As of 1980,
there was a rule change or an adoption
of a rule change that allowed it.
Why does it say,
does it say eastern only?
Is that what it's saying?
Was something in the story of the video
that was going to just kind of pause it
there.
Why is he eastern Catholic like East
Coast,
east coast,
west coast?
Not,
but Mexicans are not by the Catholic
homes.
Bullshit.
Brooklyn married in the house.
Huh?
One hundred and 20 Catholic priest
married in the United States.
Wow.
That would be great to policy change by
Pope John Paul the second in 1980,
which offered a path for married
Episcopal priest to continue their
ministry after converting to
Catholicism.
Oh,
so you have to be a priest already.
Episcopalian,
and then you're allowed to have a wife
and kids if you're Episcopalian,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
A convert to Catholicism right there.
Like Cat Catholicism is the only one
that doesn't allow them to have sex.
Right?
Yeah.
It's the only one with this littered
with kid fucking right.
I mean,
coming up,
cut the shit we were at,
we are actually at mass and he was
talking about there was one thing from
the gospel that was talking about being
married,
being with a woman,
and then he finishes his answer.
Cheers.
Happy holiday.
He finishes the,
uh,
he finishes the,
a sermon and then the reading,
then he goes into a sermon all about
being with a woman and this is a man
that doesn't come close to that.
This is a man that has no experience.
It would be so much better for the
church if he wasn't married man with
children.
And then he could really talk about
being in a family like,
who are you?
You know,
nothing about what we're dealing with on
a daily basis.
Yeah.
I never went to the Catholic Church when
I was an adult,
but I would be curious to be there to be
a husband and wife sitting there in this
fucking church.
Listen to this dude who is supposed to
be celibate drone on about how you
should live your life and what kind of
relationship you should have already
pitched.
You're dressed like a fucking jeanie did
advice to giant scarf on like a wizard
son as his posture is.
What are you doing?
What's that thing on your shoulders for
white dress like that on silk.
You have underwear on.
It's really weird that we let people
dress like that because yeah,
like if you didn't.
If he just stood up there and had to be
held accountable.
If the volume of his words were all he
had,
like if you just made all priests and I
mean all preached across all religions.
If they all had to stand on a flat
regular stage with nothing behind them
and they had a dress like a,
like a regular person like you're
addressing right now and no point.
He had no pointy hat.
No,
no fucking giant insane artwork behind
you too.
Confusing up pedestal.
All that stuff fucks people up.
You go there and you see the like you've
been around,
right?
Yeah.
St Peter's Basilica.
See that?
Yeah.
When you go in there,
I mean you almost can't believe that
your eyes are working.
Correct?
Right,
exactly.
You're almost like,
this can't be something that someone
actually made.
Yeah.
This is insane.
With no machines,
just their hands and thousands of people
like that that if you're in that thing,
you're going to be so humbled and so
they're going to get away with a lot
more shit than if you were in some weird
conference room.
Tiny little,
little bullshit ass cups of coffee.
You know how you get a coffee machine
and they have little tiny bullshit ass
cops,
White Styrofoam Cups,
a handle on it.
The paper handle,
the folds out and you're dressing Joseph
a bank once in the handle.
It not that bad because they have to be
a certain size to have a handle.
It's the that are.
They're little
white ones.
A little white styrofoam ones.
Those are bullshit.
Yeah,
but they were putting the plastic,
the little triangle,
and nobody's going to buy your fucking
connection during that place.
You have to.
You have to sell it.
You're not.
They're not just going to buy it.
If I allowed to dress like a wizard and
you stand up and I'm a golden podium
with a giant,
huge sculpture of Jesus nailed to a
cross behind you and there's organ music
playing,
you know that's it's.
That's your act.
That's a good act.
That's an act that's going to look at
that.
You know what,
man,
they should make that shit illegal the
same way they made advertising booze
illegal,
but you know what?
Look at how pretty that is though.
It's gorgeous.
So pretty.
Wouldn't be a better Christmas mass or
some bunch of belly dancers up there and
do this plan.
Bongo drums and people passing around
joint.
Just a big ole cannabis infused loving
when that'd be better than this
bullshit.
Well,
these are all just grown adults and we
can get all those grown adults just
passing out.
We'd singing songs together.
Well,
what was it in New York was at the
limelight?
It wasn't church that turned into a
club.
People in the church singing together
with that.
Come on,
man.
That's possible too.
But you know what?
Those people that are in those pews that
looked like a thousand people,
right?
That's a big crowd.
Those people that are sitting there,
they are kind of high.
They're checking their watch right now
and go,
when does enough of this guy drone?
And he's glad as sees fucking drunk.
Yeah.
Where they go asking this for money
again.
Those gin blossoms all over the face.
He looks like WC fields.
Fucking guys just getting drunk.
Shit.
Put Shit in the basket.
Now they're coming out twice with the
basket.
Screw this guy here.
You stop it.
God is going to hear you kind of going
for his doctor's appointment tonight.
What if God's can I hear you?
But as the value of them having a place
to go on that Sunday,
even though they hate it.
Important.
The limelight is a gym.
Now you have the limelight.
Was a fishbone at the line.
Hold on.
So the limelight does the dance club?
Yes.
Is now a fitness.
It was a church.
I can't tell what it was a market too.
It was a rock club,
so it doesn't last.
They started selling shit and sell that
shit.
Imagine that.
It's your house,
Tom.
Papa.
It's that would inspire you to get your
party rolling.
Live in a church.
It's the gym now.
Do.
I would work out and that church all
day.
That would be my spot.
Even if I had a gym at my house,
I would definitely go to that gym just
to feel the juice.
Like I tell people,
I say I tell people all the time,
she always like,
I like working out like at my studio,
but I like going to places too because
when you go to a place like there's a
certain amount of juice,
you know you're in a new spot.
People around you that you don't know.
Yeah,
you're right.
We're out and it's also as a comic,
I think social interaction is one of the
least respected ingredients to our weird
sort of a stew of things that come
together and make a bit.
You got to fill the well with,
with those experiences.
Yeah.
You got to talk to people.
It's like reading or just being out in
the world.
It's important.
Yeah,
it's,
it,
it just all like all those things,
like reading is one thing you needed to,
but I think like interacting with
people,
it's just too goddamn gigantic.
So important.
I do this.
I am the,
I do a monologue each week.
I'm out in America on live from here,
which is the new prairie home companion.
And Are you allowed to say that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's the new.
It's the new prairie home.
Did anybody else call you that or did
you decide to call yourself that?
What?
The new prairie home companion it is
that it was prairie home.
So you're actually doing this thing.
When I first got hired,
it was prairie hall and then they
changed it when garrison keillor got in
trouble.
You got an unannounced called live from
here.
He had a couple.
I was confused.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And uh,
and uh,
I do a monologue each.
We call the out and America long.
Have you been doing this about a year?
And don't tell me a,
it's an NPR.
I figured you would know.
I figured all things considered gross.
I follow all the shit you do.
A,
I didn't know how you follow the Shit I
do and I'm like,
yeah,
it's weird,
but my point is I do this model called
out in America and it's me,
it's me,
it's me glasses shining a light on all
the good people in America.
Right?
And I do it every week on NPR.
Wear that suit like you own it,
but the reason I bring it up is not to
plug it,
but to say it made me when I'm out on
the road talking to people,
I would get in the car and throw my,
my headphones on.
I wouldn't talk to people on flights.
I didn't talk to the person driving.
Stay in my room,
do my shit as a comic,
just go and you kind of.
You're isolated and because I have to
write this monologue each week,
I need inspiration.
I really want to shine a light on the
good people out in the country.
I started talking to everyone.
I don't take my headphones out.
I talked to the driver,
I talked to the people next to me if
they want to talk,
and it is talking about filling the well
for your comedic,
you know,
toolbox.
It's the greatest thing in the world.
There's billions of people.
They all are unique.
They all have a story to tell.
It's foolish.
Let's be as a comedian,
not to talk to these.
Be Harsh here,
but not all
have a story to tell.
Some of them,
they might have a story to tell,
but you don't want to hear it.
Well,
some are bad,
some are disgusting.
Fucking story has a story.
Got a deal that you're going to get a
lot of stories.
They're going to be coming your way.
They do though.
I mean honestly,
even like the biggest slug,
you'll find.
You talked to them about their family,
about their childhood,
about where they're growing,
grew up with.
There is a story there.
Here's his way to look at it.
You take the biggest loser that ever
existed on planet earth and if you
discovered him on Mars,
it's the biggest store in human history.
Holy Cow.
This true.
Some guy wearing a doggy mass jerking
off with a bathrobe on on Mars.
It would be like the most important
thing that's ever happened.
It's on the CNN fuck out.
They'd be like,
this can't be real closer.
I show you I'm real old man with donkey
ass beaten off.
Right?
But if you found an old man with a
donkey mask beaten off in Venice,
I'm still impressed.
I'm still shocked.
Like if I said Tom Papa,
get your life savings.
Do you say yes or no?
There is currently a man with a donkey
mask on wearing a bathrobe jerking off
in Venice.
Yeah.
You might.
You might want to lean.
Yes,
you might.
If they're bringing it to you,
I'd be super suspicious.
They'll be like,
that's your question.
Favorite.
Not An underdog on that.
My question.
My question is,
do you think that it ever happened?
Oh yes.
Everything you can think of is that
confident that someone has jerked off
with a donkey mask on 100 percent.
Like a hotel bathrobe.
Especially in Venice.
It's all about masks.
In Venice,
I'm 100 percent confident that I can say
historically,
yes.
Everything you can think of as having a
speech,
not Venice,
Italy.
Right.
Venice beach.
Right,
right,
right.
No Venice.
Oh,
Venice,
Italy with all the bright.
With all the Catholic stuff.
Yeah.
And Post the water.
Get nine people panic.
Um,
can I ask you guys a question?
Sure.
Uh,
backed away at the beginning of the
podcast when I was talking about wine
and trying to learn about it and stuff.
The one thing I don't know about wine is
when I do drink it.
I never feel that drunk.
And we've had a bottle and a half now.
Do I seem drunk?
Yeah,
you seem pretty fucked up.
Don't tell me anything you don't want to
tell me.
Do I seem that different from before?
I mean you were also fucked up too,
but.
No,
you seem fun.
Yeah.
Because I always get home and I'm like,
I have to say I was kept my shit
together pretty good.
And then I wake up the next morning,
I'm like,
Nah,
I was,
I shouldn't have done that.
Well,
sometimes you'll hear yourself like on a
podcast if you get really lit.
Like when we did that,
a sober October podcast,
I saw one of the clips realized that
truck.
We were words.
I saw the clip.
I was like,
oh my God.
We were blasted.
We're in orbit.
Oh really?
Oh,
I was listening to myself talk.
You're so hammered.
It's so stupid because I want to be like
a gentleman that can drink and alcohol
and be like,
sir,
if that is your goal,
you have achieved it.
Cheers.
Happy holidays.
He was certainly a.
because you don't seem and you did more
than I did.
And you see them exactly the same as
when we started.
Um,
I think you're projecting.
There was one point when after you
smoked a lot,
you were going to need.
That's what I did more than you.
I can tell it was a bit of a body high.
Well,
that weight is strong as fuck.
I think there's benefit to it.
I don't think there's like,
I don't think you should do everything
all the time,
but I think there's benefit.
I don't think you should exercise all
the time either.
I'll tell you this.
When I was flying back from New York
yesterday and knew he had this when I
was on the flight,
I was thinking it would be so nice to
bring a bottle of wine,
just chill with the guys and this.
That would be so happy.
And now that we're in that moment.
Yes.
So happy.
It's a good place.
I'm worried about Jamie's hips,
Jamie's hips,
so bugging,
you know that.
So the soul right actually helped a lot.
Really slant on it and breathe in and
yeah.
You know,
I have not used that yet.
I bought two of them.
I bought one for the House and one for
the gym,
but that it's a,
it's called a so right for your so ass
muscle.
So you lay on it and have it like
massage your inner gut area and works
well.
Apparently that's like a muscle that
gets knotted up on people and I had,
I definitely got it get knotted up on me
when I was a.
I was running a little too often,
was running like four or five days a
week.
It was starting to not up.
That's it.
It's like a foam roller,
but like if you could have an elbow on
that phone and you lay on it on your
back,
but a couple of different spots too.
They have like a spot in your shoulders
in the front.
But yeah.
I don't know.
Whatever.
My pelvis area.
Yeah,
that looks nice but it helped.
Right?
You feel good?
That looks good.
Yeah,
you got to.
It's weird.
The human bodies all manipulatable
malleable.
That's why yoga is so good.
Oh yeah.
Stretching in general like all that
shit.
So good.
But it's just so weird how like deep
tissue massage and all that stuff works
and how your body's like pliable stuff
loose.
It's weird.
Some things up and someone is really
good at it.
If you get a Gao and knows how to use
them.
Elbows and you needed a man fuck you up.
Uhm,
I started running with my dog,
with my lab.
Yeah.
And uh,
but I run on the road and the sidewalk
is um.
Do you feel like,
uh,
I feel so guilty sometimes that it's got
a little paws out just running on the
road.
I'm like,
is it hot?
You worried about like the hurt.
I know it's the hardness of it.
Which streets?
Maybe.
I never thought.
It doesn't seem unhappy.
She seems like she's having a blast,
but.
Well it's definitely not as good as
running the dirt.
Right?
No,
I mean probably for us either.
it's definitely not.
Yeah,
It's weird.
You know,
there's not as much give and whenever I
see people running in the cities,
I go,
I get it.
You want to exercise?
You decided to make this whole world
your gym.
That's a weird thing.
I saw her the other day.
He was crossing Wilshire.
It's just no shirt on.
Tee Shirt.
Air Buds.
Just one of them.
One of those dudes is doing this at the
fucking taking his pulse and he just
runs across.
As soon as the light turns green,
he just using the street.
This was like 4:30
in the afternoon rush hour and he's
using this place as his gym.
Amen.
That's why I like robbing though.
That's why I like running because as
soon as you go out,
you're doing it and the other nice body
to.
We wanted to let bitches know he did.
He was slim and fit.
I don't get the.
That's what it was about.
Probably more than any of the.
Totally through Wilshire Peacock move.
Yeah.
No shirt on and just run around.
Do you do yoga with your shirt off or
on?
Off?
Off with all the gals there.
They don't give a fuck.
Do their suffering.
Everyone's suffering.
Yeah.
I always keep my shirt on because I
always feel like as a man,
I'm not supposed to be there,
so it should just make it less as a man.
You're not supposed to be there.
Even after you the remarks you heard by
[inaudible].
I'm confused.
Well,
if a man is supposed to be there.
All right everybody.
Look,
it's just too fucking hot.
It's too hot.
You don't want to have a shirt on.
Know that wet fucking hot thing.
Smothering you want to work from.
I do the regular.
I don't do the hot hot one.
I want to see you in a jog prop,
bro.
Why can't a wear something that just
like like a like covers this nigga sweat
band for your tits?
Tits,
tits.
I mean,
I'm not saying I want a bra.
You sound okay for a guy to wear a
bracelet.
Will kind is some bracelets,
but it's okay for you to wear with them.
Tennis risk things.
Yeah.
It was like,
like a real band.
Yeah.
Those headbands for your risks,
those risks,
those ones red,
white and blue.
Remember those in your head?
I thought I was the coolest fucking dude
on earth.
I had a those wristbands with red,
white and blue on them.
Like that's right.
Tube socks pulled up to the knee all the
way up.
Yeah.
What were those things called?
What'd you call the bands?
Like tennis wristbands?
Yeah,
the headband and the wristband and they
probably had a headband to.
I had A.
I had one that was pretty bad ass.
You know what was a big.
It wasn't too though.
You just go the one.
You just go on the left.
That was the cool move.
There was a time.
I don't remember what the time was,
but there was a time when.
That's it right there.
Sock towered over two pieces.
Large son.
We're going to or those as soon as you.
I'm going to work next time.
Tom.
Papa.
I do a podcast somewhere.
Then red,
white and blue wristbands.
Kids.
That'd be awesome.
I literally had that fresh,
very fresh.
Felt cool.
Yeah.
Cool.
Don't.
Aren't those popularity?
I was going to say something.
A wristband.
Oh God damn it.
Son of a whore.
Marijuana combination of it being
allowed to wear him a for a guy working
out.
Sweat boobs.
Thrown a lot of information.
Why is it okay for a man to walk around
with no shirt on and women can't?
Was that what you're going to say?
Well,
there's.
That's obvious.
We women because it.
There'll be a template.
They definitely can,
but I've talked about this before.
I think I said I would just.
I wouldn't recommend it to a friend will
be like,
don't go out there.
Ted saying,
if a friend tried to ask me if they
think that they should exercise that
right to freedom and be like,
well,
I don't want to get harassed.
You don't want to get harassed like I w
would you wear like Bikini underwear?
Walked through a gay neighborhood on
Saturday night at 10:30
PM.
When the ecstasy just kicked in to dad.
You're a piece of meat to how good do
you think you'd feel walking through
like a super duper gay neighborhood with
like little bikini briefs on sandbars
Santa and for whatever reason,
you obviously shave your chest.
It's funny.
Maybe your chest is smooth as baby but.
But your back has hair on it.
It's funny because you're setting it up
as a predatory kind of scenario,
but all I'm thinking is would they think
I was okay with like,
would they like me?
Would you be pumped?
Her disgusted?
You'd know you'd be.
You didn't want the hassle.
That's what I tell my.
Yeah.
I mean,
I understand that there's like a cool
movement now and it's a time when women
should be able to go out there and dress
the way you want to dress.
It's not their problem.
It's the guy's problem.
Let's correct the guys rather than us.
Right.
I love that,
but there's a lot of guys that hadn't
been corrected yet.
Who are going to hassle you and follow
you in the parking lot.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
Those guys aren't woke once.
Everyone's all.
Whoa,
whoa.
It'll be dangerous word to use.
I feel like people are going to market
in the future.
Woke woke.
Yeah.
I feel like using woke now like
unironically super slippery.
I see a trap coming.
You do.
Did you Jitsu practitioner in me is
like,
I don't like this move.
This is a.
I know where this leads.
Right?
That's how I feel.
Yeah,
I see that woke thing.
I'm like,
what are you woke?
What the fuck does that even mean?
Woke up.
You woke up.
What do you 12?
Well,
it comes from my 16 year old,
so yeah,
it's kids today,
but what is being.
It means your brain is open.
You're open to stuff.
Your problem is.
There's no real quantification.
There's no real.
There's no test you take to show that if
you're woke.
Right?
Right.
Like if you want to be a mathematician,
you have to fucking show that you know
how to do math.
The professor said,
check your work like you get through
like,
yes,
congratulations Tom.
Papa,
you are a mathematician,
phd in mathematics.
It says right here on the paper.
You're like,
God damn it.
I'm going to put that shit on my walls.
You understand?
I know how this stuff works.
Yeah,
but wokeness,
anybody can claim to be a master of
wokeness.
It's like Kung Fu without fighting.
It's very dangerous.
Yeah.
No one's defined what's woke and what's
preposterous.
No one's defined what's,
what's just not racist and sexist and
not homophobic,
but open minded and aware of the
failings and the misgivings of all sides
of us and with no bias.
Right?
Is that.
Well,
because it doesn't seem like it is.
Isn't that woke?
I don't know,
I don't think.
I think you just described what I
thought it was.
I would like that,
but too many people could jump in.
There's no.
There's no real clear understanding of
like what makes it constitutes someone
being like,
yeah.
How many of those boxes do you have to
check it?
Like stopped Tom?
Papa had a woke academy and you took
these people.
It would just been to you like bread or
not like bread claiming wokeness.
Super slippery.
What's his 62 New York Times magazine or
being woke crazy.
Dig It.
Look,
if you're woke,
dig it.
Oh,
that's the perfect definition right
there.
If you're woke,
you dig it.
That is insane.
That was my Fox man and you were copying
my taste and grit.
We don't jump salty on me.
Whoa.
Look how they talked back.
Then they were trying to talk people
into talking the way that made them seem
more interesting.
I'm going to say it the way I would say
that if I lived back then hey,
could make it bigger so I can see why
you'd be the guy on the left.
Jimmy.
No,
no,
no.
Scrolling,
so we could read what they were.
Six comments.
What he's saying.
Up Top.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was,
that was my facts man.
And you were that grace and grit.
So how would you say that now?
Um,
that was my fox man cop in my tastes.
And of course it's girl boy,
girl.
And you were saying no,
that's what they said.
Oh,
we'll use.
What words would you use today?
Yeah,
yeah.
He would say the fuck he doing with my
girlfriend dickhead.
And he said,
don't jump salty on me.
I would say,
hey,
we're cool.
No worries,
no worries.
Stop being such a bitch.
It's all good.
Yeah.
And then it'd be like,
what?
Someone's a bitch.
And then next thing you know,
people will be hitting each other.
That's a darkened snowman with these two
gentlemen to the left,
it says Noah Webster.
I think that might be like the webster's
dictionary.
A Guy Peter,
Peter in the dictionary.
This squirly the letters are all
blurred.
Right?
I love that.
If you're woke,
you dig it.
Yeah.
If you're woke,
you dig it.
That's,
that sums it up,
man.
If you're woke,
you dig it after a.
how'd you find this?
Jamie?
Come back to that typed in.
It's like know your meme.
Oh Wow.
So the meme of the word woke.
Wow.
Look at that little image though.
Scroll back up.
So it again.
That's so strange.
Like I'm bad.
Shift was contemporary.
Like if that was your world,
like imagine if hipsters all of a sudden
started wearing tails.
So their jackets,
they just decided this is the next level
of bow ties and those tails.
It wouldn't be surprising because that's
all about just doing what you guys don't
do.
So what a weird look though.
It is.
It is so weird.
That's a look that like,
okay,
so like the guy in the center,
it's like those two guys,
both of Gods in the center.
Those guys will fly today.
Oh totally.
The guy in the left that looks like he's
dressed like he's a.
That looks like me on the road,
but he looks like he's an acquaintance
Tarantino movie or something like he's
reservoir dogs.
That's totally normal.
Really blend the matrix.
Black suit tie,
that'll door.
I can go to any restaurant anywhere and
no one would even bat an eye.
They go,
Whoa sir,
can I help you?
Boom,
right in with the gun image guy next to
him.
But those two guys on the end,
like,
what in the fuck are they?
He's got a coat with tails and those
pants that are like flat across your
crotch where it looks like you have no
privates.
Here's a good way to look at it.
Imagine if you're dating a gal and a guy
come over and you're like,
you're really gonna.
Love my dad.
He's an amazing guy.
He's real old school and dressed like
that with coat tails.
Yeah,
and you start feeling like you're like,
you're in the movie.
Get out and he's got a handlebar
mustache.
He's got tails.
Yeah.
Weird,
weird pants with the going to funny
shoes.
You see.
Get Out.
Yeah.
I finally watched it during sober
October.
Oh,
you did?
Fucking fantastic.
Yeah,
that's.
But that's what you'd be thinking if
that guy was dressed like that,
but the daughter was going to lead you
to something and you have to run for
your life.
But it is weird how like that suit has
lasted a long time.
Well this was 1960,
so I'm assuming that it was mocking the
style of old.
So by the time 1960 rolled around,
the guys in the middle where trust
contemporary,
but the guys at the end,
they're like making fun of people the
way they used to dress.
Yeah.
Kind of in a way or at least that's what
represents those people.
Yeah.
It just defines their time.
That guy was probably around the 18
hundreds.
Where were those other guys are?
Do you know who those guys are?
I believe Noah Webster.
Webster.
Webster dictionary.
That's why it's got the pen and he's
scratching his head.
Is that guys putting out his slang?
His slang is making websites.
What the fuck?
He's like,
that's not how you really say it.
So it would be like the urban
dictionary,
like,
oh,
Jamie and I sometimes get confused.
We have to pull up the urban dictionary
and find out what the real word of a
word means.
So let's pull up woke.
Yeah,
represented today.
You know what?
No disrespect.
No cultural appropriation intended.
The fact that it was invented actually
in the sixties.
It was really weird.
It was just making a comeback,
looking around when I typed in,
like what is woke to see if there's
anything and she,
if you dig it,
you was saying
were knowledgeable about your community
in the world with the willingness to
access and critique systems of
oppression a.
well that part.
Exactly,
yes.
I mean for sure if it really is a system
of oppression,
but how do we decide what's the system
of oppression and what is sounds like
you need Jordan Peterson,
weird human behavior that represents
that interact with each other on a grand
scale.
I mean that's just,
like I say,
there are some legitimate systems of
oppression,
right?
Yeah.
For Real.
It's like figuring out which one it is.
Yeah.
Before,
but putting that in,
that's what woke is like how do you do?
How do you define what the system's
like?
Where does,
where does the line get drawn?
Right?
It was the line like,
why do women have certain jobs?
White men have certain jobs.
How much of that is because of
influence?
How much of that,
because of their choices,
how much of that is just because of
natural proclivities towards certain
things?
Well then you're talking about people
that are coming after the hierarchy and
if they're coming up to the hierarchy,
who's to say that those people are in
part of the problem?
I love Jordan Peterson.
The.
It's just like hammers.
Just.
Yeah.
Well then what do you want?
What are you saying?
Who are you?
What are you buying into the hierarchy?
You're loved like the exasperations in
his ways.
No,
but it's true.
It's like then this true that that woke
definition was like,
oh,
I'm with you.
This is all about being nice and kind.
And then at the end it's about
attacking.
Right?
But here's the bad crazy.
The thing is the end part about
attacking is where it gets weird because
Jordan Peterson is the guy who gets
regularly attacked,
misrepresented,
like.
Especially in terms of like that.
He is somehow or another a racist
because some racist like him.
I've heard that argument.
It's crazy.
Argument doesn't make any sense.
He's not a racist by any stretch of the
imagination.
He believes in individuals.
I mean,
he's more Ian Rand then it.
I never say that.
Right.
I know her name's Ian Rand,
but I always say I grind
really like a natural instinct to fuck
it up,
but it really is like.
His thing is it's like the power of the
individual and responsibility and doing
your thing and he's.
He's understanding.
Of course during this time,
of course he's under attack,
but he's also under celebration.
Yeah,
he's under.
He's been celebrated as well as attack,
but much more celebrated.
It's under celebration more that he's
under attack.
He.
It's nice to hear that viewpoint
articulated in such a clear,
concise way.
He's a genuine sweetheart of a guy.
I mean,
I think if people knew him.
I think part of the thing is some of his
views are very powerful and polarizing
to some folks who have a specific idea
of how things are and what things should
be and what would.
What represents Transphobia,
what represents sexism,
and you know,
these are all fascinating discussions as
long as everybody's just being rational
and.
Yeah,
and being honest about it,
but yeah,
it's good.
It's moving,
it's moving the discussion forward.
It's like you should hear all sides and
you should hear what he's saying is,
you know,
in a lot of ways is very true and very
real and it's like,
right,
but the presentation of it in these
times,
it's like he's very brave because he
knows that anything he says there's
going to be a shitstorm in response.
Well,
he's very brave in that respect,
but it's also very brave in that he's
done a tremendous amount of research on
all these different subjects he was
talking about and when he talks about
something from a scientific perspective,
he's not talking about it because it
aligns with his beliefs and he will in
fact highlight things that don't align
with his beliefs and show that he has a
hole in some of his thinking.
He'll,
he'll,
he'll pause in midsentence and goes,
well,
I guess I'm wrong.
Then he does.
He has a hundred percent of intellectual
honesty.
Yeah,
he's just,
he's not scared to take on this system
of the way people think and behave and
this system works both for really
progressive,
open minded people that support most of
the things that you and I probably
support and it also.
The system is also in place for people
that have more stringent conservative
viewpoints and we have to look at
everybody.
Honestly,
if you want to debate whether someone's
opinions or one thing or the other.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'm with you 100 percent.
The problem is when you start calling
someone a racist and calling someone a
racist because you think that racists
like him or calling someone the sexist
because you think that sexist like him
or because he say's says things that you
don't agree with.
If you don't agree with them and you
just dismissed them at this as this
really shallow sexist opinion.
The problem is other people got to read
what you're saying.
They're going to look into it and it's
going to seem silly because the guy has
volumes and volumes and volumes that you
could read and that he has books.
He has all these different lectures
where he discusses these things,
podcast,
we're discussing these things and really
complex and well thought out ways that
you can't.
You can't say his race and what's
fortunate.
What's unfortunate is that he presents
this stuff.
We should then our responsibility is to
deal with the stuff,
deal with the ideas,
not what does it matter who he is,
how he talks,
what he is and who cares,
but the problem is the idea is what we
should all then,
oh,
thank you.
Take it whether you like it or not,
take it and then wrestle that idea and
move it for 100 percent,
but we also have to be aware that
there's a real problem and calling
someone a monster is not a monster
because then when real monsters come
along,
you already used that word up,
right?
That's this is like you have to be
careful because there's real racist in
the world.
There's real bad people,
so calling someone a bad person just
because you don't agree with them,
you fall into a very slippery
ideological trap and a lot of times
people it just to get attention.
They want to throw their hat into the
ring.
They want their,
their,
their say they want,
they want to get it out,
they want to make an impact.
They want that love.
Yeah.
They want to be part of that.
I want to be part of the discussion and
they might have very strong beliefs that
they think are correct,
but I guarantee if you,
if that,
those strong beliefs are that Jordan is
a racist,
you don't know him well,
there's no way you could write in.
There's no way you're really familiar
with a lot of the things that he says
about race because he doesn't say
anything racist.
He talks in terms of.
I mean,
he,
he always emphasizes individuals.
The most important thing
that's,
that Ian ran thing.
It's not about that.
It's,
uh,
it's about the person you responsible
for,
you doing you despite whatever comes at
you because everything's always going to
come at you.
Yeah.
It's an.
And it's not a denial of racism.
Racism is fucking horrible.
But what it is,
is,
is saying that we can all,
we can all figure out a better way to
navigate this.
Then the shitty way that racists and bad
people have done in the past.
Right.
You know,
it was kind of racist.
I was.
I wanted to put African Americans in my
Christmas village.
Good.
And you go online and try and look up
African American figurines for whatever.
It's.
It's not good.
They haven't not yet woke.
You've got there are.
There are prisoners.
There's prisoners.
There's like worker,
like there's not a lot of like just
regular families.
There's definitely a lot.
Wait a minute.
White people.
Okay,
let's,
let's get this.
Let's get this before we look it up
because this might be one of the
untapped things.
If you've got to get outraged about.
Is it possible that you can buy ceramics
slave?
Yes.
You think so?
Well through a store,
maybe not on the Internet.
Ebay for sure.
Really?
Yes.
You know how much stuff was put out into
the culture of like a Alfalfa kind of
representations of kids and slave
children.
And how about that?
There was,
I mean I went through my grandmother's
like keepsakes at one point,
like a shoe box of stuff and she just
had a postcard from her friend.
It was to like black kids eating
watermelons and I was like,
grandma,
what the hell is this?
I was like,
you know,
15.
She's like,
oh,
it's just a joke.
But she wasn't it.
I only bring it up because that was
circulated,
that was being pumped out all the time
in the culture.
So there's definitely stuff you can get
second hand on.
Jamie's got a big smile on his face,
a lot of different slave stuff like
Roman slaves,
slaves that like put long as their white
slaves were good there.
You pay me some Roman slaves that
address like there were in that girl at
gladiator movie,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
You have to fight
and I got some here.
Okay.
So this is non,
it's not American.
So all those slaves.
So like that's isn't an interesting.
Like it can't be like it's got to be
like I didn't do it out.
Can put them guys.
None of my people made them people
slaves fucked up,
bro.
Right.
Like you have to have Middle Eastern,
ancient starts getting a little
squirrely.
100 BC.
Oh,
the rowers.
But those are white people that gray,
three d printed that haven't been
painted.
They look like Henry Fonda or up to the
person who buys them,
you know,
to make them as accurate as they write.
It looked like Henry Fonda,
Kirk Douglas,
they had some white ass features.
So white hair,
they've got white people hair,
you know?
I mean just put up racist dot.
Seems like an easy search.
Just stumble across actually.
Yeah,
you're good.
Good call.
Yeah.
You just don't want certain things typed
in now.
Exactly.
You know,
it's like that.
Like the Alexa thing.
Do you have an Alexa at home?
Lex is listening right now.
I know that bitch.
My friend told me like,
you really should.
You really should take that off.
And I'm like,
why?
I'm like,
it's only when I talk.
She's like,
no,
they listen all the time.
There was another murder case and they
confiscated the Alexa because they know
the Alexa will have information from the
last four days up to the murder.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
But it still plays my music,
so I'm keeping it.
You don't care.
You're not killing anybody,
so this is.
What is this a doll that you could make
a slave?
It says it's like say like,
it's not like play,
play mobile or something to push the
Lego rip off.
He's got lego hands chain around his
neck.
I'd be mad if I bought that.
I thought it was a Lego.
That's funny.
Like even if you were a kid,
your parents,
like you said,
I want Lego's and your parents brought
you that.
You're like,
bitch,
this is not legos.
Wack ass.
It's supposed to represent a pirate who
was formerly a slave in historical
context.
It's easy to write that sentence.
Then to make a new lego was a former
slave in a historical context on that
is.
What does that mean?
I don't know if that means present a
pirate who was a former slave in a
historical context.
That means he escaped.
I know,
but it's a weird way to put it,
isn't it?
Isn't that weird?
It's so ridiculous.
Racist Toi instructions.
That's the news title.
The question mark that was fucking
misleading.
News titles,
racist toy instruction to them after the
break and he made a fairly light notice
how conservative they were.
You know,
they didn't make them super dark even
they knew that was the.
We could get away with that.
We can make them kind of brownish.
That guy looked like he had a tan.
It looks like he was a,
like a Spaniard.
Yeah.
You know,
like the Nigga Montoya,
you killed my father.
Prepare to die.
Like that's what he looked like.
It is.
Like if he looked like a spanner on a
holiday where they caught a nice tan.
Are you saying even the racist toy maker
was like,
no,
dude,
don't go too dark.
Yes.
I'm just saying the racist toy maker was
like,
you know what,
we just gotta we gotta play it safe.
Go with,
go with this color.
Yeah.
Go shoot for Guatemala.
That's it.
That's all I'm looking for.
Do you go to mass on Christmas?
No.
Mass at all.
I go to Willy Wonka's golden chocolate
factory.
Wow.
It's all nonsense.
Why would I do that?
I'm just asking tradition because he
grew up there.
I.
No,
I never grew up that way.
You did church when you were a kid?
Yeah,
we did,
but it was for a very short amount of
time to say I grew up that way.
It would be hard because it was.
I was out by the time I was out of first
grade.
Oh yeah.
We're talking about putting me back in
for second grade,
but we moved from New Jersey to San
Francisco and uh,
we didn't find a Catholic school on a
scale of Catholic schools.
Cost money to went to public school
after that.
But I was just done.
I hated it.
I was in fear of those fucking crazy
people.
And your parents didn't take you to
church or make you go?
They did a little bit.
I think the idea was back then that if
you had kids,
you wanted kids go to Catholic school,
you know,
there's a lot of people that did that in
that neighborhood.
When I was little,
it was just a normal thing you did and
they were more strict and too.
Dude,
one thing that was for sure though,
like I had a conversation with my mom
bought at once.
She was like,
you know,
your grades were way better when you and
you're a Catholic school.
And I was like,
yeah,
because it was fucking terrified to get
wrong.
They beat the shit out of you want to
live like that.
They never beat me.
Then I definitely threatened me.
Really?
Yeah.
They threatened to make me sit on a
nail,
going to have to sit on a nail and the
uh,
in the closet.
Stay here all night.
I hope you brought your blanket.
They're like really mean when you're
like a little six year old kid,
like,
that's fucked up.
It's just a weird,
oh,
we stuck with these people for nine
months and to also for me it's like my
parents were splitting up at the time,
so it was very confusing and then I
wanted things to have order to them,
so I wanted God to make sense.
I remember annoying people with that,
like six years old.
I didn't know any people talking about
what God wants.
What do you mean?
Like you,
God says this,
God wants that.
Like I would say that,
Oh,
you would bug six years old because I
was a little kid who's dealing with my
parents splitting up and there didn't
seem to be any order in the world and it
was very nervous.
Right?
So when I find when I went to Catholic
school,
when I first got there,
I was,
I was happy that I was going to go to
Catholic school,
but then as I experienced it at six
years old,
I started going,
this is ridiculous.
This doesn't make any sense.
I'm like,
first of all,
these people are so mean.
They're,
they're obviously being mean and nasty.
They're not comforting.
And I was seeking as a six year old
comparing them to weigh like my was.
My mother was like,
these are these ladies were nasty being
so mean and I'm like,
these,
they don't represent God.
And I was like,
this is crazy.
And then you could see kids getting in
trouble because their parents hadn't
paid for their lunch or these and there
was like this really,
you tell your father to get that money
in.
Like there was a weirdness to it that
just didn't seem loving or it didn't
seem like what I thought of when I
thought of,
you know,
Christ and when I thought of it seemed
to me like,
oh no,
this is a dark little trap.
Get sucked into.
So that's what's remarkable about that
is not just the age but that you went
from a really,
really meeting it in a very real way
because what was happening with your
family to like normally you wouldn't
turn that quickly.
Like within a year.
It sounds like by the time I was.
Yeah,
it was over by the time I was out of
there.
Usually that change doesn't happen for
15,
20 years outside of beating me or doing
something sexual to me,
the,
this,
the mind fuck of dealing with those mean
nasty ladies.
Scared the shit out of me were crying.
They were calling me a baby because I
was crying.
I was like,
Whoa,
just not knowing how to deal with human
being when you're a six year old and
this is going down and you're like,
what have I done?
Yeah.
Like I went from always being with my
mom or being with my grandma,
my grandfather.
I was like,
everything was cool and then all the
sudden you go in school and this is what
you're doing in school.
I didn't go to kindergarten.
I went to first grade.
It was the first thing I went to,
so all of a sudden the first grade is
like instantaneously being connected to
these crazy ladies.
Jesus.
I was like,
oh no,
poor.
And then I would think about them.
I don't think we'll kind of like
thinking about why this will mean.
I remember being six years old thinking
this right.
I'm just like,
nobody probably loves them.
Like they don't get.
They don't have a family.
You have a boyfriend.
I didn't think at the time they don't
have a girlfriend,
but maybe they do Holla,
but for sure they didn't.
The whole thing was that they didn't
know.
They didn't have anything.
No connection with another human being.
What would it be?
Lonelier or more angered inducing.
Yeah.
It was just dark.
There weren't.
There weren't loving people.
You know any of your children.
They ask about it.
They didn't even bring it up.
We,
we've talked about God and I.
My.
My basic take is Jordan Peterson said
something really lovely.
He said he behaves as if God is real.
He behaves as if God exists.
Interesting.
Not that he believes God exists because
that's sort of a.
it's a bit of an intellectual trap where
you say,
do you believe God exists?
Like,
okay,
define God.
Then you're in the weeds.
Yeah.
Because do you think that.
I think that there's a city in the
clouds.
No,
I don't right now.
I don't do.
What do you think that there's an energy
like we were talking.
Is it possible that there's something
bigger than all of this thing?
Well,
this bigger than everything.
Like if you talk to an aunt and said,
hey man,
do you think their cities,
its skyscrapers and airplanes,
like,
what are you fucking moron?
Get out of here,
bitch.
I'm trying to drag this dead bug around
talking anyway for your fucking galaxy
talk universe talk.
Get the fuck out of here with your five
g pitch at a time.
Dragging this bug.
I mean in our perspective,
when we're talking about things like
we're.
We're so small,
we're the way we interface with reality.
So crude even though it's amazing.
Yeah,
but I liked the idea of the not going
into the whole intellectual discussion
about God,
but just like just,
you know,
who knows,
just kind of act like he does exist.
It's a great way to do it.
Does make you.
It does make you act a little kinder.
Yeah.
It's like a parent figure.
It's like,
okay,
we're not going to do this because it's
going to make them unhappy.
I try to do what are the,
like when I'm at my best,
I try to treat people as if they're me
living another life.
Treat.
Treat people as if they're just,
you know,
don't think people as a bother or don't.
And it's hard to do.
It's hard to do,
especially when you're busy or when you
have your kids with you or when you're
trying to get something done.
It's hard to do.
I try and walk,
walk around thinking everybody is
drowning it insecurity,
right?
That really kind of makes me give people
a pass in the biggest and smallest ways.
Everybody when you see people hustling,
do whenever businessman,
businesswoman,
looks like she's on top of her game
person,
like on the subway,
who was obviously going someplace.
They don't want to go with no money in
their pocket.
If you realize we're all just drowning
and insecurity,
it just makes you just give them a
little bit of a a pass that that's been
where my head's at,
been at lately.
That's a great place to keep your head
because we all are.
Everyone's balled up everyone.
Even the person you admire the most is
like,
ah Ha.
Well,
you know we were talking about earlier
about the traps that you fall into is
you're trying to achieve and do things.
You're also fall into traps even when
things that you love and you can get so
caught up in a,
you know,
the things that you love that you kind
of forget to keep your,
you know,
you're,
when you're at your best.
What feeling or keep that in close
range.
Yeah.
I feel like getting away from you
because you're too tired because you're
working too much because he pulled that
back.
Yeah,
keep.
Keep it at close range where you are
operating at your best,
but be respectful of that.
Right,
and I think this is something that I've
been guilty of in the past.
I wasn't respectful of the energy that's
required to be at your best.
I just figured I'll just do all these
other things.
Yeah,
but you only.
I really firmly believe you only have so
much bandwidth in a day and this is
coming from a person who pushes their
bandwidth too hard all the time.
I think you only have so much in a day
and when you get to a certain state,
you up diminishing a lot and then I
think you want up diminishing a lot of
the.
All the other things that you do,
like if you.
If you have like seven things cooking in
the background on your phone,
it's not going to move as fast.
Allegedly actually does work that were
some computers,
but people do that too.
You have too many things.
Cooking.
Yeah.
We all do all the time.
All the time and then you take 20
minutes of transcendental meditation and
take your nervous system and put it on
restart to and just let it wash out.
You hypnotize me Bro.
This thing in hand,
it's freaking me out.
Let it wash out.
Twenty minutes.
Okay.
Because we're all under that all the
time.
One hundred percent frazzled.
No matter how hard you're pushing or
just coasting.
Three o'clock in the afternoon,
2:00
in the afternoon,
4:00
in the afternoon.
That nervous system is shot,
right?
We're all the same.
How do you.
Twenty minutes,
what do you do?
Talk me through it.
You take your nervous system and it's
the result of it is you come out and
you've rebooted the system and you can
now have a good part of the second part
of your day.
Do you have a technique used?
Do you use an APP?
You know,
I went to.
I went to a transcendental meditation
teacher.
Oh,
and in without the hippy dippy.
That's the biggest part of it.
It literally makes you realize just what
you said.
We're all just frazzled and running out
of steam.
At a certain point,
your nervous system is shot.
All that stuff that's happened just
between 7:00
and 3:00,
whatever would happen.
You're that nervous system has been
dealing with a ton of stimulus all day
long.
That meditation gives you a reboot and
you can it.
It's like a needed thing that's better
than sleep that you.
You're actually a yearns for.
I'm telling you,
since I really started dialing it in and
did it in the best way I can describe it
as that.
It added another four hours to my day.
Whoa.
Yeah.
How so?
Because I would just be limping across
the finish line.
I'd be exhausted,
I'd be trying to do and with motivation
and I work really hard.
I would push through and get to maybe
two hours more of what I needed to
accomplish.
When you do this effortlessly without
struggle,
I'm able to just sell like I did between
nine and 12 that day.
Really?
Yes.
A hundred percent.
Do you think by using this practice your
alleviating tension so you're more
efficient with your energy,
like what makes you?
That's part of it,
but it really is.
It really is taking this nervous system
that is dealing with the outside world
all the time and just giving it a real
practical way to shut down flat line and
then come back on the grid.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and it it like your physical body needs
a rest.
Your things need to be rebooted.
Your nervous system is kind of this
thing that operates all the time that
we're not really that conscious of.
We're not really that aware of that.
How hard it's working and this is a way
to pay attention to it and give it a
chance to regenerate.
That's interesting and it's going to
been doing this,
you know,
I meditated for like since college,
just out of reading books and then
probably about three years ago,
uh,
my friend said who always did
transcendental meditation.
He said,
go,
just see if it dials you in.
It actually the stuff you are doing,
the way you talk about meditating,
it sounds more laborious.
It sounds like you're doing too much
work.
Just go talk to this guy.
And I did for like three,
four sessions.
I went and talked to this guy here in la
who was a transcendental meditation
teacher and he just explained it,
dialed me in on it.
And for the last three,
four years I've been just,
I haven't missed a day and three or four
years.
Yeah,
every day.
Every day.
Seven days,
seven days,
no cheat day.
Cheat Day.
How long?
No need for me.
It's the opposite of what you want from
a cheat day.
It's like 20 minutes.
Where if you can get to in,
that's the best.
If you can get one in the morning and
one in the afternoon,
then you're like superman.
Wow.
But if you can get one in,
I'm telling you,
start to finish how long?
Twenty,
20 minutes.
20.
And you do this everyday.
Everyday.
Maybe that makes sense man.
Because a,
it's the things that people remark about
you is how easy going you are.
Like the like people have said,
dude,
I love and Tom Papa was on your podcast
because it's so easy.
Go like did you guys Gel so well
together?
Flow together.
If you're tuned into president together,
we're just,
we're both,
you know,
you're kind of not struggling and that's
what it teaches you.
You just see this is a big roaring river
and it lets you just kinda go
underneath,
catch your breath and then come back up
into it.
Do you feel that way when you exercise?
Do you feel like when you exercise you
get into like a zone and you reset your
brain?
For sure.
I feel less.
I feel less depressed when I exercise.
Like if I'm in a funk and I'm like and I
go for a run,
I'm like,
my day's different.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's almost like a.
That funk is trying to hold on to
control too.
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's like it's tricking your brain.
Do you feel like shit.
Today I was like,
let me just put these God damn shoes on
and go run.
Yeah.
You know,
you feel so good,
but the meditation is different.
The meditation is like,
the run will give me energy.
I won't feel so shitty.
I'm like,
I'm okay.
I feel good.
I feel alive,
whatever,
but the meditation in a very subtle way,
five hours later when you're faced with
a stressful situation,
you don't feel as stressed as you
normally would because it's just you're
near your nervous system,
which is very powerful.
Has Been rebooted,
is now able to go and deal with another
situation.
You should go see him.
Okay,
I'll do it.
I'll give you the name of the guy.
He's amazing.
I mean,
he's not amazing.
It's not a guru.
It's not the one sperm guy.
It is not about him.
One minute.
It's not about a religion.
It's not about a people drop of Mush.
Sperm dot does will not give you his
sperm.
He's just delivering the message of this
little practice,
which is very.
It's not hippy dippy.
It's very practical.
Practical and can use it.
Yeah.
It's,
that's the best part of it.
Would you,
have you tried the tank before in the
float tank now?
Would you be interested in doing it?
You know,
we have one here.
You can use it anytime you want.
I would like.
I'd like to hear what your take on it
is.
Yeah.
Especially.
Especially if you wanted to practice
those techniques in there.
Yeah,
I think that'd be really interesting.
It's crazy environment,
man.
That would be great.
Yeah,
you should do it.
I'll do it.
Yeah,
for sure.
Not Today.
I'm drunk.
No,
but there's a,
there's also,
you know,
there's a bunch of big places around
two.
There's the float lab down in Venice and
they have one at Westwood and then
what's the big place that's in Pasadena
has the biggest one in the world and
people that come in like a gym.
Yeah.
He sign up,
go in there and float password.
Got a giant.
Just flew.
Yeah,
just float in Pasedena shoot.
They don't.
They have like 40 fucking float tanks
with some crazy shit.
I don't know how many they have,
but I think they use all float lab stuff
too.
That would be cool.
What's another interesting thing?
If you get the morning one in,
you know how sometimes you wake up,
you've slept,
you went to bed at 11,
right?
You're up at seven,
but you're exhausted because your
night's sleep is restless.
You've got up to pee a couple times.
Who knows?
You look back at your bed.
It was just a disaster.
You do those 20 minutes before you go
about your day,
just before the kids get up,
just get 20 minutes in.
It's like a you.
It was more valuable than what you tried
to accomplish in that eight hours
spinning around in the sheets like
especially for someone like you,
right?
Who's job is to create things.
Yeah.
Right.
To put your mindset and to put into a
particular place is super beneficial if
you're just creating things all on time.
Totally,
but it's for everybody.
Right?
Right,
right.
It's literally like,
yeah,
we're all just human beings just
struggling everyday going out,
doing all this stuff and it's like you
could be a single mom living in the
city,
taking the bus to work after dealing
with your kids and go.
Her nervous system is being bombarded.
Yeah,
20 minutes just kind of sit in there
on the bus.
You could do it on the bus by your with
all this other.
It's not a a pristine thing.
It's not a hippie thing.
It's not an.
I was gonna say elegant,
but it is kind of elegant.
It's not a special thing.
It really is just like a,
like a controlled that in a way and
it'll.
It just gives you more to go on.
We're all,
everybody,
no matter what you're creating,
no matter what you're doing.
We're all under assault all the time,
right?
Yeah.
I mean not,
you know,
don't equate it to war,
but there's like bombardments of energy
and stuff that's coming after you all
the time.
You have to kind of tend to the system
that's dealing with it
that I think anything that gives you a
perspective reshift or reboot is great.
Yeah.
Anything,
whether it's going for a swim in the
ocean and whatever the fuck it is.
Something that gives you a perspective
reboot.
We,
we get caught in some pretty gross ruts.
Perspective.
Reboot is a cool way to say it.
Yeah.
I think um,
we have these views of the world sort of
we have this,
um,
these,
these patterns that we sort of recognize
and we see them,
they're out there and we get locked into
them and we're just visiting the same
websites and seeing the same people and
doing the same things every day.
And sometimes you need something
different.
Some.
Yeah.
The knock you out.
You need something that gets you to
think about other stuff,
you know,
maybe it's going to a place that.
This is why I travel so good.
I used to never get traveled when I was
a kid.
Yeah.
That's like,
what the fuck wants to travel.
I like being home,
but one of the,
I do like being home,
but one of the things about travel is it
allows you to experience the feel of
someone's culture in real life.
Like you're walking through the streets
of Cologne,
Germany,
like you're like,
wow,
this is how these people live.
It's crazy.
We walked through the streets of Rome.
It takes you to of yourself.
Yeah.
It gives you this.
First of all,
it gives you this appreciation that
there's different rules over here,
but these are still people.
Modern people just like you and then
some of your ancestors came from here,
but here they are where there's
different rules.
Millions of millions of them,
and then they got people that are coming
into them from Africa and it's like,
whoa.
Like this is crazy.
I guess this whole thing is fascinating.
This is a.
and then were around,
you know,
Pompei and you've seen the ruins that
mount vesuvius erupted,
killed all these people,
and you're wandering through all this
stuff.
Like this is fascinating.
Yeah.
It's a long way from thinking about the
three apps that you sit on your phone
every day and get your news and get your
thing and check your instagram and
facebook.
That's a whole nother whole nother
mindblower Oh my God.
It's a whole universe of other stuff to
think about.
That's why I love walking in New York,
like you have your routines of like
where you're walking on the other side
of the street and go the other
direction.
You're a wild man.
It's a whole nother world,
but really it's just literally like when
you're your run with your dog and you if
you just look the other way from when
you normally are like doing your thing.
It's a whole nother perspective.
It's a whole nother world.
It's crazy,
right?
But literally just looking the other
way,
running the other direction.
It's this true,
but look,
it's not a small thing because we liked
the order we like that provides calm and
safety.
If you're just going that same route all
the time,
but then there's a limit I guess,
and you end up.
It starts acting negatively on your life
and your height.
If you're just a constant vagabond
traveling around the globe,
that's probably not.
Not Positive either,
right?
Yeah.
Always going on.
Never having a home.
I love home.
Yeah.
I love home too.
I love home,
which is so weird in a.
In a career where we have to travel so
much.
Yeah,
but one thing that I love to say like
equated to good knievel,
but that there's some weird sort of
balance in this life and that we do
really have to experience negative
things to appreciate positive things for
what they really are.
If everything is positive,
if you're the lottery winner when you're
five and you win that golden power
ticket,
$500 million.
Jamey.
When you're five years old and it's all
made,
then you don't have to imagine that you
growing up,
it ruin your life.
Like,
listen,
little Tommy,
you never have to work again.
It would ruin your life.
Talking about grandpa bought a lottery
ticket when you were five.
If you'd be so nice to give us some of
that money,
that would be nice.
But if you have $790,
million dollars,
like what?
GRANDPA?
Yeah,
GRANDPA put it in a trust and it's all
yours and you can have it.
Yeah,
when you turn 18,
but you could give us some of it now and
just sign right here.
Come on Bailey.
Be fucked.
Imagine growing up being like richie
rich.
Yeah,
you'd be a mess.
You'd be like,
what the fuck?
Be a massive,
a face full of cocaine chasing this
feelings that you can't get just from
practical everyday work.
Cute.
Imagine.
Remember that fucking commercial?
The cartoon.
Richie rich.
Oh yeah.
Comic books everyday.
The day.
Every year at the Jersey shore.
I get his comic books.
He always had new ones.
That's got to be one of the weirdest
cartoons of all time.
A really rich kid.
Really when all the money in the world,
all the poor kids would read it and go,
fuck,
I wish I was richie rich,
man.
This guy's gotta.
Go Cart.
It will get them seeing their Scott
Bachelor's.
He's got a Sunday chocolates.
I want my little dear boy.
Comfy while he takes a nap t and he
says,
oh,
well thanks mom.
Thanks candy.
And there's a butler dressed like that.
Dude with the tailcoat coincidentally,
but look at it,
look at the name of it.
It's richie rich,
the poor little rich boy,
right.
That's what it was.
The poor little rich boy because he's.
Because he's not happy like he's really
said,
well,
first of all,
look at the size of his ankles.
Kids got gout.
He's got the gap.
Check out for sure,
but the dude who's got the Ice Sundae,
he's the
same.
Dressed the same as.
Go back to the picture please.
The dude with the ice cream Sundae is
the very top.
Yeah.
He's wearing the same clothes that were
mocking him and he's wearing the tails.
The whole dot.
James got the whole getup.
The 18 hundreds get up.
See?
I used to think about a guy like that,
like in the shining or something like
that.
Then there's some Butler and I would
think of,
oh,
that's a proper man.
That's a man that he's the guy from the
shining and he's just gonna come over
and be proper.
But yeah,
normal normal.
But then as I got older I realized,
oh no,
no,
that's a guy.
But it's just a guy and this guy has
this fucked up job.
Whereas to dress like he lives in
another time period and the weight on
all these rich white people.
Like what?
In the.
It's a tortured man right there.
If you were a serious black rapper,
like one of them guys with diamond
teeth,
wouldn't you get a diamond white
servant?
Like that guy?
Yeah.
That's good.
Cut All white Butler's.
Yes.
I'll wipe Butler's just like super,
super high end guys from England.
Yeah.
Professionals.
It's true.
I don't think he's a professional boxer.
Hilarious.
I love diamond teeth.
Yeah.
Little Richie.
Rich.
He wasn't happy.
Was Cadbury Cadbury?
Perfect.
He had perfect butler.
Cadbury was his butler.
Oh,
perfect.
Butler.
Bring over that Sunday.
Look at that other poor kid.
He's all deformed and shit.
He looks like he's evolving.
Another kid looks like his grandparents
were Australia.
Pithy.
Kiss enriched.
Rich.
Just like,
oh,
let's show you what it's like to be
rich,
rich.
I never had these neanderthal looking
fella.
I never sat at a table before.
Blow that picture.
That kid again out.
Tell me.
It doesn't look me into tall as he is.
He has a monkey face.
Straight up does.
He does.
He's got totaled neanderthal things.
Lawyers are real low,
isn't quite big enough,
but they definitely gave him some odd
features.
He does look terrible.
Yeah.
He's got a bald patch in the back of his
head.
We'll see you in a bulletproof scalpel
or a little guy or a little fellow.
Who was his name.
Oh,
no,
fuck face.
It's really rich.
Cadbury and his friend.
Fuck face girlfriends.
He's going to get all the girls.
Yeah.
That is hilarious.
At the bills I.
So it was one of them.
His mom,
the lady with the blonde hairs.
right?
Oh,
but the girl with the blonde hairs,
his mom.
Right?
Little Auto Lot.
A lot of their names are written down.
Little Lotta little glow.
Christ.
They're all his girlfriend's little lot
of get it.
She's big.
Get it.
I'm not.
I'm.
I swear to God.
I'm having flashbacks from every summer
as a child.
I'd go to this bookstore and their big
comic books and I buy these little rich
richie rich comic books and go home and
read them.
Lucky he's looking at his shadow is a
dollar symbols for shadow.
When did,
when he's got a girlfriend,
when is a bad ass rapper?
Gonna.
Recreate this picture for the covers
album.
I think that would be perfect for like
Gucci Mane.
Richie rich.
Yo.
Come on and tell me that wouldn't be
having them walk away cause he's.
Oh,
he might've already done it because it
takes a lot of pictures with his lovely
wife.
There'll be a perfect picture for Gucci
Mane and his wife honey dollar bill
behind them.
Hollow dollar bail.
Y'all check.
It's so weird.
Right?
What a crazy idea for a comic strip bay
area rapper named Richie rich.
So.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
And I don't remember it being like the
weren't really sending a message.
Just like money isn't important.
It really literally is awesome when you
want to be Richie.
He could get ice cream whenever he
wanted.
It was always the thing too.
They're always getting ice cream.
Cadbury,
the Butler frightfully fit.
Oh yeah.
This is a rich one.
Should keep fit.
I exercise a whole lot of time.
Interesting.
Cadbury,
that's literally the lines.
That's the comedy.
The size of her arms.
They're like Ham hocks.
She just mounts you and just wrapped
your head up and those arms and smothers
you to death.
You try to chew your way out,
but you run out of air.
You run on an air.
Oh,
interesting.
Those meet flaps.
Kitobah here.
God battery.
And if she's ever in trouble,
she could literally leap off a building
with those things.
Just glide to safety.
Jabber is Cadbury fucking Jack.
He takes off his look at them on the
left.
He's going into a hot tub.
He's got a towel on and no shirt.
He's ripped.
When did Cadbury?
We came and looked at him.
What a butler.
Well,
homoerotic.
Ah,
what a but so strange.
Wait a minute.
You're putting your.
Oh God.
Look what he says there.
Gosh,
I've been keeping you from your bath.
Cadbury.
I'm sorry.
Please go.
No need for apology.
So some day I shall relate the story of
how I was once lost all my clothes at
the South Pole and they says what a
Butler as he's walking them,
walk away with his tiny little towel
around his junk.
Look,
a little of that town was where do you
even find a towel?
That little that makes it way all the
way around your ass.
Yeah.
He's going outside and you got to make a
choice.
You covered your Dick.
Are you covering your asshole?
But you definitely not covered in both.
With what kind of strange snake like
towel or you possessing six inches
across 12 feet long.
Yeah.
Cadbury gun on the Jews started lifting.
Got a fitness coach.
It's so funny.
That was very homoerotic.
It was weird.
They were allowed to do weird stuff back
then.
Imagine if you had that cartoon today.
Fucking feds show up at your door.
Hey Tom,
papa.
Let's see your fucking hard drive.
Another one of the pedophile conspiracy.
Creepy Shit.
Fuck he been up to Tom.
Popular podcasts is five hours long.
How long have we gone to?
Three hours in a half at least right?
15 Tom Papa,
so easy to talk to my friend.
Do you have anything?
You're selling to the wine.
My pleasure.
Stick around for a while.
I don't want you to drive it anywhere.
They could listen to my podcast.
Okay,
come here.
Come to papa.
And what is this other thing to npr?
Did a pre live from here?
It's called live from here.
From here.
Every week.
Six o'clock.
Six o'clock east on your national public
radio.
Whatever.
And uh,
when are you going to be at the lovely
comedy store next?
Probably tomorrow.
Oh Shit.
You got to work out some stuff.
Sold out.
Show in the main room.
Yeah.
Okay.
Tomorrow PM show.
I'm there folks.
We just made a booking.
I'm on.
All right,
thank you everybody.
Bye.
Great.